foreign
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's friday yeah it's
gonna be a good show tonight yeah i
think so yeah this is a classic case
jimmy hoff
i'm actually surprised we haven't well
like i said you know when we first
started the show we didn't want to do
kind of these more big ticky like better
known cases because like so many other
things have been done about it but
finally finally we decided to get around
like talking about it ever since i was a
little kid i mean a little kid
i grew up
with the television
every now and then in the radio every
now and then one was somebody on the
television or radio wondering where the
[ __ ] jimmy jimmy hoffa was he just
disappeared off the place of earth well
it's kind of like it kind of became a
joke for a while like even in movies and
stuff like that people would be like oh
hey i found jimmy hoffa you know what i
mean like just it was it was like this
meme before there was even a word for
that for sandra no cassandra she was in
there seduced by a sexy couch
she wish i had no idea the [ __ ] you
talking about i i vaguely remember
something like that i don't know what i
was talking about she's got to refresh
my memory
but
she'll take this the littlest [ __ ]
thing i say have a [ __ ] run with it i
don't even remember saying that kind of
[ __ ]
but uh because it's the poltergeist that
says it i guess especially when i've
been drinking i'm trying to drink this
one up fast that way i can get more
[ __ ] ahead into the future
i'll drink that [ __ ] i will go into the
future did you know that that's that's
good okay all right i'm trying to like
i'm trying to get this drinking out of
the way so i can do more drinks i can do
more drinking in the future right
so you see i can tell what time it is by
what color i had i'm on i'm still in the
black hat when i'm on this hat i'm in
the future okay because this one's next
all right then
when you see me in that [ __ ] conan
wig you know i'm at the end of time
yeah i'm at the end of time anyway uh
jimmy hoffa was a teamsters union leader
he was teamsters wendy yeah yeah
teamsters and i know he was a union
leader he was heavily entwined with the
mob
all those unions were
uh they probably still are to a certain
extent but uh the labor unions were all
entwined with the italian mob of that of
that era
and he made a bunch of mistakes and
[ __ ] he disappeared
they they know he's dead they just don't
know where the body is yeah and a lot of
people who were involved in the mob over
the years you know put forth what they
think happened to him they pretty much
know why he disappeared they just don't
know where he is
um
i think there's one guy i think his name
might have been jimmy to something other
than was it jimmy the greek one of them
i forgot he came it wasn't
one of them i forgot his name he he put
forth the best
theory of what they did with his body
and i'm gonna stick with that but i'm
not gonna talk about it until the time
comes well i was watching a documentary
about this and one guy who was like a a
true crime writer
he said what may have happened why there
are so many plausible sounding theories
as to what happened to jimmy hoffa and
why like so many of them sound like you
know oh it's coming from a guy that was
there and would probably know is that
what they might have been doing was that
you know obviously like all these people
in the mob knew what had happened to him
yeah but they were like if they ever
told anybody they would tell everybody
like a different story yeah well yeah
that's [ __ ] dude yeah they're they're
clouding the information yeah like a
misinformation campaign then all of a
sudden the cops go and look in all these
weird areas they keep [ __ ] digging
and looking for this dude and they're
always coming up with nothing and that
way they just [ __ ] stop believing
they say yeah [ __ ] jimmy hoffman that
was the idea
i will say though that the recent film
the irishman yeah
yeah the martin scorsese film which is
actually a really good movie but pretty
much everybody i mean that kind of um
hinges on the theory that frank sheeran
uh aka the irishman was the one who
killed jimmy hoffa
and they had like the whole scenario and
everything and even though when you see
the movie that seems kind of plausible
um
most of the like so-called experts that
i was reading and stuff like that said
that is probably not what happened
um but it's a good movie anyway the old
school mob
at this level at the highest levels and
that's the level hoffa was at were
[ __ ] pros they were really good
i mean um intelligence agencies worked
with them and learned from them and
adopted back in the old school this goes
back to even world war ii
they worked with those guys in in in um
covert operations uh and learned from
them and sometimes employed them
those dudes were
would not rat each other out not at that
level they would never roll over
so whoever did it would go to their
grave it was a small team of dudes
they knew each other like brothers
nobody ever said anything
after it was yeah and like you said they
probably purposely spread around a bunch
of different plausible sounding stories
so that no one would ever know i think
whoever did it their outer circle knew
that those three dudes did it but they
didn't know we needed the details of
what had happened yeah that would
because everything would have been
compartmentalized and and everything
would have been deniable
and then the guys outside that ring
their job would have been to spread
rumors
of what happened which like i said that
seems like common sense that that's what
you would do if you were uh engaged in
these types of nefarious activities the
best theory which we'll talk about later
and again
of what happened to him is i believe the
one that happened and if they did that
there would have been no remains when
they were done with him
well that seems the best way to go about
that kind of thing if you want to make
somebody disappear then literally they
literally
there's ways they had access to methods
that would do that
yeah industrial methods that would do
that there would have been nothing and
that was the idea that there would be
nothing yeah nobody to find
yes vaporized much harder to prosecute
somebody when you can't find a body it's
not impossible it has been done but very
witnesses and there were never going to
be any witnesses and no one would ever
testify those dudes were all bro blood
brothers to each other they would not
roll
yeah okay so there's a couple like super
chats and a couple comments that i
wanted to answer uh jeffy art says happy
friday guys jenny i just finished a cold
moon over babylon the amulet and the
good house oh my god amazing books yes
all of those are good although i haven't
done i don't think i've done the amulet
yet but i have it so i just haven't uh
reviewed it yet uh i said yeah
recommending them to my friends yeah
those are all excellent got all kinds of
super chat uh sandra was seduced by a
sexy cow said it's always a good show
i'm here for the side tracks anyway not
for the topic
i think a lot of people are that's which
makes me feel a little bit better in
cases hopefully i don't like mess
anything up lady bazoovia says is that a
summerton man t-shirt yes it is uh i
made this actually
yeah that's summertime man it says who
is summerton man on it yeah it's one of
it's one of our thirteen collections
they're all great
stuff uh see who is this thank you the
sexy cow that seduced sandra
okay
for the super chat sorry sucker okay
that cow's in here
sandra says middle ages witch trials man
[ __ ] cow and said it was the cow's
fault it seduced him yeah
and then they executed them both yeah
that's uh some [ __ ] that they would have
done back then
it's those sexy big brown eyes
oh my god everybody's coming up with
that he's in he's in block of concrete
he's buried in this net no
no they wouldn't do that
that's that was that's part of the
misinformation campaign
they had methods of acts of literally
vaporizing a body there is there is no
jimmy hoffa the body's gone i believe
because they had access that seems like
a lot of a lot of experts say that too
they don't know exactly like where when
or how it happened but they're basically
saying there would be no either that or
you got dumped in the ocean
now too messy they would want to know
for sure that there was no body yeah and
there's a process that you can go if you
just dump it in the ocean it might wash
up somewhere you can watch it happen and
five minutes later there's no body
and you know there's nobody
job done
[Laughter]
yeah
uh and thank you for the super chat
jeffy art always love your podcast thank
you very much
uh sheila anne is yeah this was a this
is a very popular uh theory that he's uh
buried in the end zone at giant stadium
like report him in the uh thing but yeah
i've heard i've heard uh that a lot uh
thank you david june i'm here [ __ ]
can't wait for those cases they wanted
them to go and dig that up over there by
the [ __ ] yankee stadium and then oh
he's not there giant stadium a giant
stadium and then and then the cops would
look like fools that was the whole idea
yeah it's like this they're like we're
not doing that holy crap sandra said
jenny looks cute today well thank you
yeah not as cute as the cow though
sandra's going to have to jog my memory
well i mean you know no one's going to
talk about they were giving the cows
vitamins and steroids i said cows alone
just as attractive as they are i think
it's something like that sounds like
that was like back into 30s while they
they didn't know they weren't really
sure if vitamins or steroids worked
they didn't really have steroids as
you'd know them they were prototypes
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that they didn't
that they didn't have agents to make
something stable they didn't have that
beowulf says the moral of half a story
is don't get involved with the mob yeah
it almost seemed like
i don't know it almost seemed like he
didn't really
intend to but it was almost kind of like
back in those days
you know getting involved in union
organizing stuff like that you almost
like had to be most of the government is
like that and yeah so it's kind of like
you know
and he was kind of like using those
tactics like to get what he wanted which
in some ways were good for like some
like the working people that he helped
and stuff but
not so good in other uh in other ways
and a lot of times in certain areas
there was a kind of a shade of gray
where business ended and the mob began
and where politics ended it was all just
kind of the same thing
um well and i think that that was one of
the things that jimmy hoffa people like
him like said they're like look uh you
know the other side is using these
tactics so if we want to get anywhere we
have to do pretty much the same [ __ ]
right you know what i'm saying if we
want to get anything done right and uh
you know they're
just because you say somebody's in the
the mob or you know
the italian mafia that's not really
saying much because there was a lot of
different mafia families and each one
was of different standing and you could
con and make up your own mob and you
didn't necessarily have to be italian
you could be a junior member or an
important member and you're not even
really italian
i'm a junior mom
[Music]
they were just gangs
and you know you could kind of make up
your own
some of them you could trace them back
to sicily
but that didn't matter even by the time
the 20s was around you know they had
guys who were irish that were doing that
in those italian mobs kicking ass yeah
make a lot of money getting famous and
being well like i said frank sheeran the
guy they made that movie about was yes
yeah he was irish dude yeah you know
they they called the italians this is
back before
a lot of times this is back before
italians were considered white
yeah we were talking about that
yeah and it's like it even in my
lifetime like in the early 70s like when
i was a really little kid i remember
reading stuff from like the 50s and 60s
yeah as if the italians were not as if
the italians were yeah like they were
like these big weird foreigner types
like ooh you know even like italian food
which nowadays is like as american as
anything else was like considered like
weird and foreign which is like very
funny to me yeah now italian is just
like as white as irish because the irish
weren't white either yeah that's true
when you went back far enough
whiteness is just kind of like a [ __ ]
a made up american thing
it kind of is in a way [ __ ] you all
of everybody eventually just becomes
white if you're here long enough
the hispanics are becoming white
they're saying well these are white
hispanics
when i was growing up in brazil i just
blended in with half the population yeah
and yeah they were hispanic hispanic
just means you know they're part of the
spanish empire you know a descendants of
the spanish empire and the diaspora yeah
that doesn't mean anything about racism
necessarily it's a [ __ ] that's that's
a
it's a [ __ ] terminology hispanic
doesn't mean anything
spain is right next to germany in
england that's [ __ ] crackerville
oh god crackerville that's crackerville
the royal family is married to each
other and and the castilianos up in
castille were basically germans but so
were the british the british were
basically germans they were sexually
[ __ ] man
jesus but um
yeah so yeah now they just said well
they're they're hispanic but that's a
white hispanic
you know it's [ __ ] funny and then you
find out that that white hispanic is
also jewish
yeah it's these these terms don't mean
anything
yeah you know i mean you know they're
just kind of
political opinions people uh political
labels you're
just
a little depeche mode for you
sandra said wasn't there a jimmy hoffman
marilyn monroe connection not that i
know of although uh
hoffa and the kennedy brothers jfk and
robert kennedy like hated each other
holy crap that was like blood feud [ __ ]
so much so that
um i don't know if this is necessarily
true but so much so that people thought
that maybe jimmy hoffa was involved in
the like jfk assassination because he
was apparently super happy when jfk got
shot yeah um i don't know if that's true
or not i'm just saying that that's like
you know that's something somebody said
yes what i was going to say and i kind
of because i got went off into a rant
forgot what i was saying
what else is from
[Laughter]
the italians from the italian
perspective
they called all pretty much all white
non-italians the irish
whether they were irish or not i mean
they had you had to definitely not be
an anglo of some certain other for them
to call you something other than an
irish like if you were
hungarian then maybe they would call you
a honky which that's what the hungarians
kept me hunky
i was looking that word what what uh
where that word came from honky hunky
it's hungarian
interesting i never really knew the uh
the slang term for a hungarian the
etymology yeah
yeah that was a word that was used in
you know like
evidently according according to my
research it may be wrong but it says
that
that was like in the new york boroughs
and stuff
that was just kind of the slang term for
anybody who was kind of eastern european
probably hungarian but it'd be easy to
mistake a romanian for a hungarian it's
just if it's a language you don't
recognize and it's eastern european
they're just going to say like i don't
know they just sound like vampires
yeah
they all just sound like
[Laughter]
and for some reason other african
americans that that term stuck with them
maybe they lived in there started off
that word came from a neighborhood that
had joined a neighborhood that was like
that that sounds plausible and it got
into into and then it just got into the
vernacular yeah anybody who was white
was a honkey but they were talking about
hungarians
that's interesting i didn't know it was
that quite that specific it's like
cracker
okay
i always thought that a cracker just was
because the cracker is white but my
grandmother from the deep south she
clarified it no cracker means cracker
jack
and that was like colonel sanders was a
cracker
and they were just
they were basically lower middle class
or middle class
white southerners
that were trying to be gentrified as
much as they could and they'd wear these
[ __ ]
suits
used a lot of times they were white
suits but they were also pastel colors
and they'd sit around on a down porch
drinking tea and [ __ ] and mint julep
yeah and
pontificating
and being [ __ ] trying to sound
important and telling other people what
they should do that that's what a
cracker did
and because they were cracker jacks kind
of like like a pimp or a mac
just
walk around looking
good and trying to tell other people
what to do just on the back of the suit
that you were wearing
[ __ ] i got a white suit on okay you do
exactly what i say that's right now
that's right usually they were faking
i'm gonna try that [ __ ] out they had the
same thing in england they called them
dandies well yeah and they were usually
working class but they tried to look
like they were rich
that's what a cracker was cracker jack
looking sharp
yeah
that's what that's what they're talking
about
right so you know cracker we're gonna
[ __ ] um walk around tell people what
to do and [ __ ] you know if you told a
black person what to do he'd probably
talk down to him back in jim crow era oh
no hey boy hey what you need to go back
over across the railroad tracks yeah be
sounding like you belonged over here be
sounding like foghorn leg horns right
right so you know
they're just going to see some crackers
showing up too when you get back where
you belong and that's good for them it's
going to be all white people are
crackers no it's just the crackers that
we're telling you to [ __ ] go back
over there on that side well like i said
you have like limited you know
exposure to that kind of [ __ ] you're
like man are they all like that [ __ ]
yeah right well the crowd was like the
cracker of that era was kind of what you
would call in modern terminology if that
would be afghanistan that you would call
that a tribal elder
you know i'm talking about doesn't have
any authority on the authority he's just
he's hanging out there
you know he's he's assumed authority
yeah just on the back of nothing really
that's the tribal era their elder is
because i'm old i'm telling you what to
do
there's no government yeah and that's
kind of pull that [ __ ] with you yeah the
deep south really didn't it was all
local there wasn't any [ __ ] real
government structure to mostly my little
light went red but it went back to green
again so if it like gave a little blip
i'm sorry about it yeah we're kind of
sandra said i'm in the kitchen for a few
minutes don't talk about something funny
i don't want to miss anything
david june says nice tyrell corp shirt
tom thank you uh we got them for sale
yeah because uh we made that we made
that uh it's a big hit at work one old
lady misread it as genetic republicans
though
uh don't even don't even get me started
seriously that's super funny
i think it's funny because i think i
thought i kind of read it as that one
time too when i was like not really
looking at it i was like wait what oh
yeah that's right um yeah so camp guy
said there used to be a lot of haufa
style gangsterism in the georgia state
house eugene and herman talmadge yeah
i've heard those names before it's just
well
i don't know like i kind of feel like
this is an interesting case just because
i mean everybody pretty much knows what
happened to the dude i mean the mob
whacked him right yeah um it's just it's
just a mystery because they never found
his ass and no one is like saying why
like who did it yeah and and part of
what i was leading into you reminded me
what you just said
it's hard
the mafia families
were kind of self-made families
they were not highly structured there
wasn't a top-down command structure
between them all
any criminal organization could become a
mafia basically
um
the one that got hoffa was a very rich
and powerful one all right you so you're
not talking about
they may or may not have been connected
with very many other mafia families
because a lot of those other mafia
families would have been a lot poorer
and lower in social status
that's one of the reasons why this
crime was never solved
this crime was done by a really good
rich powerful
mafia organization i suspect it was
something to do with the genovese crime
family yeah that's what i'm saying right
so this so these were the families that
you would know about for everyone that
you know about there's 20 other ones
that you'd never know about because they
were too small and insignificant and the
reason that they whacked him i think was
because they suspected right layer
wrongly that he was going to uh become
an fbi informant and like talk about all
the uh ties between
labor organizing and the mob and they so
they thought he was going to blab so
yeah so they bumped him up that's what i
think yeah and that's that's about right
now uh strangely enough political
parties
and unions and private securities and
um
private detective agencies are all kind
of joined the the further you go up the
food chain
the more it looks like organized crime
the same thing happens in the in the um
political and corporate world people
that
have very important lawsuits against
other people turned up committing
suicide or turned up jumping out of
[ __ ] buildings and this has just been
going on forever if you have money
you're knocking [ __ ] off
it happens
well yeah like i said if you have the
money to [ __ ] get away with it yeah
and if you have the cops on your sides
and judges and [ __ ] you have dirt on
people and you have lots of money and
you're infiltrated into the system and
you are the system like you he's he's
too dangerous to be left alive you know
he's he controls the courts i remember
mace windu and the [ __ ]
that's what they're doing okay
and um it's strange that over the years
many people that had very
heavy lawsuits against rich people who
have famous names turned up dead
in a so-called civilized country like
the united states
very strange
camp guy said what was hoffa a character
featured in the latest scorsese movie
the irishman yeah we brought that up um
actually the irishman
is essentially about
uh the death of hoffa and that the
irishman aka frank sheeran uh was the
one who killed him because frank sheeran
apparently wrote a book about
uh that whole time period and when he
was on his deathbed i guess he said oh i
was the one that killed jimmy hoffa even
though they were friends like he like
turned on him and stuff but as i said uh
that was a great movie uh which we
reviewed but most of the experts that
i've seen like talking about this case
um say that it was probably [ __ ]
that frank sharon probably did not he
was there like he was around but
um they don't think that he was the one
that did it i think even like some
people even said like the iceman that
kuklinski did it didn't he say that he
killed jimmy hoffa i don't know i don't
think he i don't think he did but no i
mean i he said it but i don't think he
actually did it i think he just said it
because
it's a famous case and he's like yeah i
went in on that actually i don't
remember him actually saying that he did
it i think he did yeah although
the way kakinsky was it wouldn't
surprise me if he led you to believe
that he did it but then he kind of
denied ever telling you that he did it
that way there's plausible deniability
it's probably like something kokinski
did do some [ __ ] i don't know if he oh
he did yeah i don't know if he did
everything that he said so that stuff
sounded like where's that cave
yeah some of the stuff and we did a show
about him before and i think i kind of
came to the same conclusion where i mean
he's dead now right so he can't like
come get me but um
i'm pretty sure he's dead yeah but um
even though he did do like a lot of
horrible [ __ ] he was a hit man no one's
denying that but i think that he was one
of those guys that to kind of inflate
his reputation
would take credit for a lot of things or
like say that he did this that that he
didn't really do or made it seem like a
lot more gross and graphic just so
people would be afraid of him um you
still would have called him mr clancy
well that's what i'm saying i'm not
saying there weren't legit reasons to be
afraid of him because there were i'm
just saying he probably didn't even need
to like inflate the [ __ ] but i'm pretty
sure he probably did though so i don't
think that he actually killed jimmy
hoffa but i'm pretty sure like he
either said outright or implied that he
had yeah but like i said i think that's
just because it's like
easily one of the most famous like
missing persons slash murder cases in us
history right
he was a big dude he was [ __ ] very
hot-blooded
but he could kill you cold-blooded
fashion
and he was just big enough and meaty
enough to just
slip up behind you and just [ __ ]
choke you out into oblivion he needed
weapon but he did use him he used every
method
including explosions
remember that he planted bombs
poisons
shot gun blast to the face he was
well-rounded he did everything
he was a well-rounded hit man one dude
he just killed with a wire
oh my god that'd be a good t-shirt too
wouldn't it well-rounded hit man with
all with a bunch of different weapons on
it yeah that'd be super funny kill to do
the wire while the dude was taking a
piss remember that that's not behind him
garrett did him turned around not cool
kuklinski i mean at least let him finish
up there smoking a cigarette while he
was dying
and then [ __ ] dropped his ass and
walked off
that's cold outside
[Laughter]
see that's a problem that seems like it
really easily could have been avoided
it's like you just wait till he's done
peeing
and then you don't have to worry about
it well yeah i know yeah
yeah i'm gonna kill this dude when he's
like on the on the can like with
explosive diarrhea that's like special
and stuff
you get them when they're [ __ ] not
ready
so they're you know you're trying to
imagine it's not a fair fight it never
is
well you know yeah why would you go into
a fair fight
yeah that's a yeah that's the suckers
right there
if you're not cheating then you're not
winning you know what kind of war is
this would be [ __ ] cheating
that's how they do it that's what makes
special forces so special they're not
following the [ __ ] rules
that's why that's why it works yeah
camp guy says i wouldn't believe that
david berkowitz has evolved into a
gentle uncle david crosby type but a
born-again christian yeah a lot of them
go like that in prison though and i'm
not sure how much i
i you know i just don't know how genuine
a lot of it is i'm not saying you know
maybe it is sometimes but it was a long
time ago berkowitz did that you changed
a lot over the years
true i don't even mean he doesn't belong
in there though
well yeah i don't think they should let
his dumb ass out because i think a lot
of the way a lot of times that when
serial killers or murderers do that kind
of [ __ ] it's because they want to look
good for the parole board you know they
want to get let out and [ __ ] like that
so
i don't know you really really really
have to be careful with that kind of
[ __ ]
uh saunders said didn't the iceman dance
in a gay club in a funny suit and kill a
guy while dancing yeah yeah i've yeah
i've heard that story yeah that sounds
like some [ __ ] he would do he spilled
cyanide on him concentrated cyanide on
him he went into his skin and it killed
him
he had it in a drink like he was
drinking it like i said well around he
spilled his drink on him
i'm sorry he says he was dancing as
fruity as he could and he said nobody
even paid attention to him spilled it on
the dude and then walked out nobody
thought anything about it and that dude
died later
i just feel like you know i'm not giving
anybody ideas or anything but that
method seems really really
good like you think that
that would seem like the best way to do
it you're not going to get hurt no one's
going to notice anything
you can like be the [ __ ] out of there
before any of the [ __ ] goes down you
have to understand [ __ ]
you have to understand chemistry
well challenge you to find that
cyanide's using metal working but it's
hard don't challenge me i can find it
[Laughter]
it's used in used in metallurgy but it's
still you know they they keep keep an
eye on who gets it
yeah and probably for that very reason
but i'm just saying if you can get it
that seems like a really good method
because
it's it's low impact uh it's low danger
for you
uh no one would notice anything was
amiss until later on and then you'd
already be [ __ ] long gone by that
time
be risky though you might accidentally
spill it on yourself
that's true
you just you'd have to be careful about
that
but i don't know it seems better than
just like [ __ ] shooting a
[ __ ]
in the middle of a big public area
though well i know i know
he just wanted to get the guy in public
you thought that was the best way yeah
yeah see he was always around he had
people with him all the time so he had
to get him in public
and that's what he could come up with
like i said that those yeah that's
pretty good pretty good i'm sure you got
a video game called hitman it has a lot
of that kind of [ __ ] in it
in case you want to practice for a
future career yeah
some he's bald too like me see
oh so that's why you shaved all your
hair off you're contemplating a new
career movie yes what it is into the
assassination technologies i was gonna
get uh
i'm going straight vin diesel on
[ __ ]
camp guy says they gave him one six
ounce tin of tuna fish daily to eat yeah
that'll kill you eventually
saunders said of course that's a method
jenny likes it's poison yeah i'm a big
fan women are poisoners yeah i'm a big
fan of uh of poisons well it has that it
has that romantic witchcrafty kind of
vibe to it i don't know i just like that
and i like the whole aesthetic around
like little poison bottles like i said
it's witchy i'm into that plus it's like
super sneaky and i like that kind of
[ __ ]
um david june says i still think we need
a gaming show by tom yeah
i'd have to look into and see how other
gaming shows do it what the formats like
and then see how i would do it
well i don't know because you could just
do it the way you wanted to do it you
don't got to like watch other one other
ones yeah but it might be interesting to
spoon in [ __ ] you know what i mean
screen captures and stuff like that of
the game
well yeah you would have to do that
probably right but
i don't know i don't watch a lot of
gaming channels like i said i like
cinemassacre like angry video game nerd
but i don't usually watch the video game
ones i've seen a few of them because
they're funny but
um usually i just watch his movie
reviews but i don't do i don't really do
any gaming so i don't watch a lot of
gaming shows the ones that i've seen are
just like 25 year old dudes like yelling
and i just like i can't uh you know that
just gives me a migraine so i don't
watch it all right so we get ready to
start the show i reconcile oh there's
something else you want to tell people
what do we want to tell the people well
uh
got a message from um
our landlord oh yeah so we're not
entirely sure we don't know what's going
on how this is gonna turn out but pretty
sure the landlord wants me to buy this
place
buy the place or move
yeah because the landlords might be
selling the house and where did we just
rent this house yeah i looked at the
[ __ ] numbers in the papers and i
could buy the place it wouldn't change
our monthly [ __ ] bills the mortgage
would be the same as our payment so it
wouldn't affect me we could do it the
problem is
is really the
really the only really good thing about
this house is the location
i mean it's a good house
yeah for this price 10 miles up the road
and use this you could get twice a house
for this yeah i mean [ __ ] they got
houses out there for less than this
built in the 1950s out of stone look
like a damn spanish castle look like a
damn colombian drug lord mansion
they got those for sale for the same
price as this
10 miles up the road
and those [ __ ] houses are bad ass all
tile floors
big arches look like a damn spanish
castle
i'd have to look closer more closely at
it but they're they're [ __ ] big you
know what i mean imagine me up there
looking like one damn drug lord
up on the top are you gonna get a white
suit and like some obnoxious aviator
sunglasses yeah unbutton your shirt to
here get a bunch of gold chains yeah and
there's [ __ ] decks
outside in the [ __ ] garages and [ __ ]
and big vaulted ceilings and [ __ ] built
in the 50s out of stone those [ __ ]
aren't going anywhere cinderblock and
stone
thank you david june for the show and
here's two books to go for your house
purchase
i mean like i said we're not sure we're
meeting with them tomorrow yeah we're
gonna see what they want but the last
time that they asked to see us they
wanted me to buy the place
but i was like ah
i don't know if i wanna you know what i
mean this is a nice place i don't wanna
move i hate [ __ ] moving i do too
everybody hates moving moving socks [ __ ]
but
this is a good rental but i don't know
if i want to [ __ ] own this [ __ ]
we'll see we'll see that yeah well
that's what pricing that's why we're
kind of like um ambivalent about it
because for the amount that they're
asking yeah
if we
moved like like you said like 10 miles
away we could get something like twice
this better for less money because this
area is like really getting built up
and all the and all the um house prices
are going up right
so
yeah and i mean this house is what like
12 years old 13 years old and it's got
it's it's getting good shape still but
it's got problems because it's going to
need a new roof it he's got cracks in
the tile in the kitchen
the shower doors need to be replaced
fixture yeah and it's so i don't know so
we're like these are like mcmansions
they look really good they're real posh
neighborhoods that they're in
um you know i mean [ __ ] with their
own security and everything but they're
not really built to last
uh
they're built more like [ __ ] cocaine
cowboy [ __ ] quick buck type things
and uh everybody's moving here from
other states
so real estate
in this particular area right here is
going up so if we do buy this house 15
years from now when it was paid off this
thing would be worth a lot of money
probably
maybe long it wouldn't be as long as it
wouldn't be the apocalypse 15 years from
now
but the thing is is like like i said
some of those retro houses from the 50s
and the 60s that were built down here
during the classic era these [ __ ] are
gorgeous really they're they're spanish
houses spanish castle looking things
so looking at them i don't know what
they're like to air condition though
well yeah that's kind of like a big
consideration so yeah so we're not
really entirely sure like i said we got
to talk to them tomorrow they're coming
over yeah and
i don't know like i said i you know
they're gonna kick us out they'd give us
at least 90 days yeah they wouldn't do
that because they're and we've been here
a long time they have a ton of other
properties we've been here 10 years
um so they wouldn't just like kick us
out on the street or anything but
i'm pretty sure that they're trying to
offload all their properties maybe
they're sick of dealing with it or
whatever 13 homes yeah they own 13
houses that they run out
so and they're all paid for yeah they
most of them are yeah this one is yeah
this one's uh entirely paid for i think
he's gonna hit me because he tried to
hit me with 425 000 that's like nah 325
pounds no 400 425 no i just was like no
that's too much too much for this area
you can get a new house 425 uh not in
here
not in here not here like 10 miles up
the [ __ ] street 425 home which gives
you twice this house
500 000 will get you a [ __ ] mansion
and we can actually afford that that's
only like uh
two grand a month
yeah about that
well that's what the mortgage would be
yeah and it's twice the size which i
mean the rent here is 1800 already yeah
so it's already 18 so so it's already
not that bad and that also covers lawn
care
yeah so and security
yeah
well yeah that's and pool that's what
the hospital is that was the hoa that
[ __ ] 500 000 house was nicer than
this a lot bigger and had a pool
and it [ __ ] they didn't have to worry
about housing commissions it was on his
own piece of land
yeah because hm it was only about 11
miles from here i looked at it
yeah yeah look good 11 miles about 11
miles
right outside eustis
i don't know i consider like i said i
you know i don't want to like move so
far away that it's going to be a pain in
the ass to get to like downtown orlando
and get into sanford and stuff
but i mean another like 10 11 miles
isn't that big of a deal right
so i don't know we'll just see what they
say we'll have to see what they do it's
like yeah it comes at me a good price we
could buy this
that would save me from having to move
yeah it wouldn't affect the monthly
payment you could always we could always
sell it that's true and get out of it
that's true yeah but you know we'll see
how it goes like i said they're not
going to kick us out on the street so i
hope not no
but i don't know if we do have to move i
don't know how long they're gonna give
us yeah um hopefully we'll be able to
make shows though probably might miss
some but that's months down the line
probably yeah i would think so yeah so
we're kind of like in transition at the
moment because we don't know if we're
going to like be able to stay here or if
we're going to have to like
go somewhere else
yeah you know that's all it is but like
i said if we would consider moving
because of the heat no i would i would
but you know because i i i hate the heat
here it's like because i i'm from here
so i'm like really sick of it
but i don't i'm not entirely sure where
i would want to go though because
there's like a lot of places that i've
been to that i really liked but living
somewhere and visiting somewhere are two
different things so i'm not really sure
like where i want to go if i could pick
anywhere i don't know i'm happy with
florida
well yeah i know you are but like i said
yes i really don't like the weather here
i just really don't
but you know what are you to do what are
you going to do
sandra said i don't think we have gated
communities in germany i never heard of
that
it's like its own town
well sort of kind of
they're all built around the same time
it's got gates
security to get in need cards or you
need need something on your uh window of
your car to get in
there's private security in the side
and usually there's a community pool
community center sometimes there's a gym
although our neighborhood doesn't have
one they'll bring in food trucks and
[ __ ] they'll have food yeah they had
a whole like little food truck thing
yesterday got little parades parades
inside
all the houses are built around the same
time and they all kind of have the same
style and there's like a housing
commission everybody has to have
the [ __ ] grass cut you got you got a
[ __ ] old [ __ ] what's his name bt
you got btk running around town you cut
your grass or they'll find you
um you have to or you got to paint your
house
and there's only like a certain amount
of like uh acceptable colors
that way
it looks like a disney amusement park
it looked like a theme park kind of
condom
the place looks like a theme park all
the houses are on the same theme
yeah yep so nothing's out of place
i wouldn't say it's sterile but it's
posh
yeah
yeah i mean you know they're nice
it's yeah it's it's a nice but like i
said a lot of them are made quickly
and yeah so some of them are like
expensive but they're not really built
with
top of the line they're not meant to
last no because the people that build
them and buy them tended to like
plan to stay in them for 10 years and
then sell them and move yeah and
somebody else gets them
yeah i don't know so like i said this
this house i think is 12 years old it's
13 years old something like that was
built like that long ago but
you know it's still like in decent shape
but it does have like some
that's why i was talking about some of
the traditional spanish houses that are
here they were built them back in the
50s and the 60s
they were built to to kind of look
timeless they all kind of look like
1800s kind of spanish 1800s maybe
um and they were built out of brick and
stone and stucco
so they're they're permanent they're
structurally super sound they survive
storms
been sitting there forever yeah because
that's kind of something that's a
consideration you have to take a shift
because this can this like survive a
hurricane
those things have been sitting there
since the 50s they've been hit many
times
and no they're fine
and uh they look good it's just like i
said they're they're spanish style
look like a castle yeah yeah thank you
david june have btk tell me to mow my
grass and pick up dog [ __ ]
you gotta understand something
if you're living in a community like
this an upstanding community you have to
cut your grass three and a half
inches take your dog somewhere
if the dog
poops on your lawn
pick it up get a ziploc bag turn it
inside out put your hand in the ziplock
bag pick up the poop to turn the bag
inside out zip it
put it in your pocket
don't put it in your pocket people are
going to watch see you walking around
carrying a you know a bag of dog [ __ ]
you'll look [ __ ] up
put it in your pot
it'll smush a little bit but it won't go
through it'll get nice and warm yeah
i have a cold day it'll warm you up
i will say in this neighborhood's
defense like i said um you know the
seminole wakaiba trail is like right
behind the house and like a lot of
people like jog and ride their bikes and
sometimes ride horses on although you
don't see that that much
um i almost never like tons of people
walk their dog on that trail i almost
never see dogs [ __ ] on that trail
because
99.99 of people pick up
their dog their dog's [ __ ] yeah i very
rarely see dog [ __ ] i see [ __ ] sometimes
but it's usually wild animal [ __ ] like
sometimes i'll say like bear [ __ ] or
something like that but i hardly ever
see dog [ __ ] so you know get on
everybody all right let's go ahead and
start the show we've been in this for
about an hour already probably we've got
4848 minutes it's time to do it people
okay y'all ready i know you guys love
the side tracks and [ __ ] we gotta talk
about some serious gangster
serious gangster type [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] is tila anyway oh i don't know
she's not in there no okay she she's not
present she missed class she doesn't
love us that [ __ ] don't love us no more
she's missing class you know she's over
there in san francisco and then she's
like what she's doing and she couldn't
get home she had to jump all those
hurdles of human feces and [ __ ] drug
needles and [ __ ]
as [ __ ] as [ __ ] san francisco
[ __ ] spirals down the toilet
xanada said why can't tom channel a more
pleasant serial killer like bundy or son
of sam
[Laughter]
ted bunny just talked like a [ __ ]
yuppie though yeah well you know yeah
hey you know it's just average yeah he
just talked like an average white man of
the time yeah yeah well you have to
understand you know
actually oh did we i okay before we get
into before we get into the jimmy hoffa
thing can i just say you remember you
guys remember we did the sidetrack show
wednesday night and then tom was like
insistent that we had to go out
afterwards
so
oh yeah yeah we ended up i almost forgot
about this so we so we did and end up
going out like two mannequins and it
stormed like we left and it was like
[ __ ] pouring down she's [ __ ]
sitting here and i was like god damn it
what the [ __ ] you made me like put all
these clothes in now my oh my makeup's
gonna wash off because i'm like i'm
going back home i'm going back i was
like no you came all the way down here
so we got to go and guess what it was at
mannequins on wednesday night it was
karaoke night karaoke yeah it was
[ __ ] karaoke there was like seriously
i think there was 10 people there like
all day long because the weather was
shitty yes um yeah but it actually ended
up being like kind of funny though yeah
you had one dude he was about far enough
60 skinny he's wearing a sequins [ __ ]
top and bottom [ __ ] bell bottoms real
tight he had long [ __ ] curly hair he
looked like he looked like
he looked like [ __ ] robert plant
robert plant
imagine if robert plant decided to do
gay night in vegas and kind of had flat
and hadn't like fluffed his hair hannah
flooded that's what he looked like all
right and he was he sang all [ __ ]
night he wasn't bad though yeah he was
actually singing to us at the table and
he go to other 10 he was definitely the
star of the night
i'm trying to think i remember he's
saying uh getting to know you yeah yeah
of course when he drove everybody out of
the damn club
with that and then he [ __ ] started
singing and then a friend of mine was up
there singing [ __ ] ozzy osbourne okay
that was pretty good yeah he sang mr
crowley mr crowley yeah i helped him
sing that one i was singing next
maybe we gotta go back and do it again
i tried to try to get me to sing and i
was like well no you went to the dj and
was trying to get hey like play
something like play some duran duran or
some morrissey or something so she'll
get up yeah you did you told him it's
like yeah
yeah i remember
because i came over there i'm like what
do you do are you like doing some like
[ __ ] behind my back and you know
i was just he's like yeah get up there
and like sing duran duran or something
i'm just like i'm not no
that's not what i told him
[Laughter]
i asked him what was up he said [ __ ]
you have a pretty good night i said and
i said that uh you know i'm tom and uh
that's my girlfriend jen we're friends
with uh with big tom that's all i said
big time yeah big time this is we do
other posters and [ __ ] here
he says if you guys if you guys need any
posters if i can talk to jen or big time
we'll do it for you that's what i said
and i kind of look at you i kind of
laugh too because the dj because he was
just playing regular 80s music like when
there was nobody singing i had a cute
girlfriend though she could sing
oh that was his girlfriend okay yeah she
got up there and sang i think she's
saying that what's that song drops of
jupiter who the [ __ ] does that sound
like
that's some 90 [ __ ] um because as soon
as she started saying i'm like oh man i
hate the song but i'm like oh actually
she can sing though um but yeah so
and it was kind of so he just played
like 80 [ __ ] but then i laughed because
he played of all things he played
the dennis leary song [ __ ] and like
then he karaoked it and i just died
laughing
i actually i i actually really like that
song i still know all the words and
everything i used to have it on my phone
yeah it might still be on there actually
now that i'm thinking about it
train that's the name yeah that's who
does it
i can remember who did james said that
in our uh iceman episode that iceman did
say he uh
i told you yeah
he did say he did say that
i don't believe him though i don't
believe him either i just nobody does no
like i said he's just showing off
i don't think the time wouldn't like
he's dead
yeah no they wouldn't have used a dude
like that
i kind of feel like no no
and well the thing about it was that
jimmy hoffa had to know that he was in
danger
so i kind of feel like maybe the
scenario was they probably had somebody
that he trusted that's what i was gonna
say
it was one of his friends yeah that did
it had to be because he wouldn't go with
him otherwise because he'd be like yeah
no i'm not getting it it's always
it's always the the main mo is it's one
of your friends yeah and really
when you think about it that's the
humane way
think about it true you know what i mean
you don't have an enemy that's killing
you it's one of your friends it's not
really a hate thing they're killing you
out of self-defense because they know
you're gonna talk yeah so instead of
making it a bad experience they're
keeping you calm
and you know the minute your back's
turned they [ __ ] hit you with
something knock you out and then choke
you to death or whatever yeah and you'd
even know it hit you
or they pop in the back of the head want
your friends talking to you the other
guy [ __ ] shoots you yeah something
like that
business
they're comfortable and talking and
don't even see it coming and it's their
friends that do it
that's that's that's that's the best way
beezness said sammy the bowl said iceman
was full of [ __ ] too
yeah like i said he said a lot of things
i'm not saying that he didn't kill a lot
of people [ __ ] all day
but yeah i don't think he was full of
[ __ ] on everything but he just like he
just embellished a little bit he just
the whole thing about the cave
and feeding guys to the rats during the
cave i don't buy it he would tell people
where the cave was it's a good story
yeah good story but i don't believe so
the story about the ice cream man i
don't know if i buy that
oh yeah i remember that yeah that the
ice cream man taught him everything
about the ice cream was going around
killing all the kid killing the parrots
of the kids and [ __ ] and he'd learn from
him i don't think he saw that in a
horror movie i'm pretty sure
that actually i remember that movie
[Laughter]
uh oh oracle said our oldest cat died a
week ago today i'm still feeling rocky
about oh i'm sorry about that that
always makes me so sad when people say
that
uh yeah beastness that he wasn't a
hitman for the mob
uh yeah all right so
it's hard to know what what is the mob
and what isn't it yeah it's a very it's
a very nebulous
concept sure
people who may have been criminals
probably hired him to do things every
now and then but hiring him would have
been a freelance contractor yeah he's a
freelance contract
hiring him would have been dangerous
though
he had to come back and killed you
because he knew that you
he knew that you paid him to kill
somebody so that's leaving a damn
you know a loose hand somebody can like
finger me for this [ __ ] so i'm gonna pop
this [ __ ] too don't be a surprise if
you go here here's a thousand dollars
kill that dude and he goes there and
kills that dude you give him a thousand
dollars and then he comes back and goes
thank you for a thousand dollars and a
couple days later he comes and kills you
for you before you get pitched
i wouldn't trust that dude he said that
he was paid 40 000 for killing jimmy
hoffa
i'm just not buying it i don't buy it
either no i don't think so no i think
his friends killed him and nobody was
paid anything it was just to uh keep
from getting in trouble
yeah just you know constantly doing
business yeah
just he was gonna blab so somebody
needed to take him out probably yeah i
don't think he was dealing with hate
either they just he was security threat
is a security risk yeah probably well
like you said i think that happened a
lot because they didn't kill you because
they didn't like you they killed you
because they thought you were going to
like roll over on them yeah which i
think it was they didn't want to go to
jail yeah which i think was the
situation here
all right so let's kind of go into
uh the history context stuff like that
before we get into talking about
disappearance which is kind of like the
end of his life right so let's talk
about uh so he's born in
uh brazil indiana
i didn't even know there was a town
called brazilian oh man every every
[ __ ] state has an athens too well i
know that yeah i know that but i didn't
know everybody was like i didn't know
that was in brazil indiana but now now i
know uh so jimmy hoffa or james riddle
hoffa because his mom's maiden name was
riddle
uh he was born on valentine's day of
1913.
now what ended up happening was that
when he was seven years old
his dad who was a coal miner died of
lung disease uh probably because of like
the coal mine [ __ ] you know what i mean
a lot of them had the got those lung
diseases right so his dad died
and um
so pretty much from the time he was 14
years old he kind of had to like drop
out of school and get a job
to support his family because presumably
he was the oldest uh child right
so he actually never finished high
school far as i know because he had to
drop out when he was 14 and start
working
now during this time period like i said
early 20th century 20s 30s stuff like
that like prior to the depression um you
know they didn't have a lot of the labor
laws and stuff like that that are on the
books nowadays
and there was a lot of uh strife between
companies and workers
uh a lot of the there was a lot of
strikes and stuff like that a lot of
strikes like ended in violence like a
lot of companies would like pay off cops
or like you know criminals or whatever
to kind of like you know beat up people
that were striking or whatever so there
was like a lot of uh tension on both
sides let's call it tension
it was worse than that but it was like a
lot of violence on both sides right
and then when the great depression comes
along like in 1929
um then you kind of have a problem where
you have all the workers that like kind
of want to unionize but then the labor
pool was so large because there was such
large unemployment that companies could
pretty much like do whatever they wanted
they were just like well okay if you
want to unionize you're fired because we
have like a whole line of dudes
you know lined up like for your job so
you know so there's that whole thing so
like i said there was a lot of violence
around this time period
and uh so this is kind of the
context that jimmy hoffa comes into like
i said he had kind of seen
the uh working conditions that his dad
had been working in and it ended up
dying of lung disease because the uh you
know conditions in the coal mine were
not ideal
so that might have been something that
sort of like forged his early identity i
suppose
now
so in the early 1930s uh jimmy hoffa who
is now like 19 years old uh he
participates in his first
uh labor dispute i guess you would call
it
so what he did was he uh he had been
working kind of like you know just
working class type of jobs and he got
together with a bunch of warehouse
workers who worked for
kroger which is a grocery store chain
based in detroit
so
these all these workers have been
working on the loading docks and were it
was you know it was like really hard
work they weren't making enough money to
really live on i believe it's something
like 32 cents an hour or something like
that
um and another thing that the company
would do
was that
when there wasn't a shipment coming in
they would basically like you'd be on
call you had to be
on the um you know on the loading bay
right
but you know waiting for the [ __ ] to
come in so you could unload it but they
weren't paying you for that time they
would only pay you
for the time that you were unloading the
[ __ ] they wouldn't pay you for all the
time that you were waiting for the [ __ ]
but they wouldn't let you leave at the
same time you know what i'm saying so
so a lot of workers thought that was
kind of unfair which it is you know what
why should you have to be there on call
and they're not paying you for it
so that they were kind of like disputing
that
um so you know you wouldn't even start
getting the hourly rate and wage until
the shipments came in and you started
unloading the [ __ ]
so what ended up happening uh you know a
bunch of the workers including jimmy
hoffa who like i said he was 19 at the
time they said okay well here's
something we can do when a shipment
comes in um which this particular
shipment happened to be a bunch of
strawberries and they come in on ice
so obviously you have to like pack them
up and get them in the like warehouse so
like pretty quickly before the [ __ ]
spoils right because they don't have
like you know fancy refrigeration and
all that [ __ ] like we have nowadays so
jimmy hoffa and other workers said well
you know if we just like stand here and
leave all the [ __ ] out here
until you know they meet our demands
then um you know maybe we'll get them to
budge on it and that did actually work
because it was a big shipment
and kroger did not want to incur the
loss that would have come with all of
these strawberries going bad so they
said okay fine we'll actually pay you
for when you're waiting around rather
than just paying you for when you're
unloading the trucks
so uh oh moving further ahead moving
further ahead to the future
i'm getting closer to my destination
sorry i couldn't swallow
yeah
okay so
this particular um you know thing being
like it was kind of like small time
because it was really only one company
and they weren't really asking for
anything
super crazy they were just saying hey
can you like actually pay us for the
time that we're here instead of just the
time that we're moving around you know
what i mean so kroger said that they
would do that like i said it was limited
but
uh you know jimmy hoffa i guess
his sort of
role in
you know leading or organizing this
particular strike
um
kind of made him
you know put him on the radar i guess
now
a bunch of the people that he was uh
were he that he worked with at the time
that worked at the kroger uh you know
grocery store at that time that were
unloading that helped him with the
strike um would kind of stick with him
for like years and years like going
forward will like be part of his inner
circle or whatever um they actually
called them the strawberry boys because
you know it was strawberries
so at this point uh in the 1930s
he kind of gets a little bit of a name
for himself in detroit and so he decides
that he's going to uh join up with an
established union uh so he could like
kind of help them out so he starts so he
joins up with the teamsters now the
teamsters had actually been around since
the late 19th century they're called the
teamsters because it was originally just
it's like a um like a shipping union it
was like
you know in the 30s it was truckers but
back in the old days before they had
trucks obviously it was horse-drawn
teams so they had like you know
wagons with like horses uh drawing the
teams so that's why they're called the
teamsters thank you david june i'll be
buying a co-worker a fat boy t-shirt
just gonna pay it off with this chat
message you later for details okay all
right all right
so thank you very much uh for that so he
joins up with the teamsters uh like i
said who had been around a long time
they were it's mostly like a trucking
union
uh or shipping industry union
so
basically uh all the him and the other
strawberry boys that had like helped him
out with his uh initial strike um you
know
they kind of like applied to join the
teamsters
so the teamsters let them in and uh
noticed that jimmy hoffa was actually a
very good um activist very good
organizer uh he was good at like getting
people you know people he was a likable
dude and everything like that so they
gave him a job as an organizer um and
kind of uh wanted him to sign up new
members
among the truck drivers
in detroit
so that was kind of his first
you know
big introduction i guess to like the
labor movement he would go around
one thing they said he would do was that
when the truckers were like asleep in
their trucks he would go up and like
bang on the truck doors and like wake
them up and then he would like start
talking to them and like try to get them
to like join the union right so that's
kind of uh what he did and he was
actually very successful at this
um because
at this point in the 1930s when he had
joined um the membership in the
teamsters had kind of like it wasn't
going down but it wasn't really going up
either but him joining um actually got a
new a lot of new members into
the union because he was a really good
at like convincing people to join it
now um so
that's
the thing about it it's funny too
because when i said he would go around
like knocking on the truck windows they
said a lot of times he would get um one
of the first things the truck driver
would do was that he would come out the
truck door like swinging the tire iron
or whatever because he thought somebody
was like robbing his truck because that
was something that would happen a lot
like if the trucker you pull over to
like to rest like truckers do nowadays
at the rest stop and um you know so it
was like some [ __ ] highway robbery
going on somebody to come up and try to
like steal all the [ __ ] out of your
truck
uh so
so he uh he didn't get to be he didn't
get beat up during this time period but
it was kind of like i said it was kind
of like a rough
time
around this time like with a lot of the
uh disputes and everything so you know
but he was uh
i think the reason that a lot of people
liked him and that a lot of people
related to him he was a little dude i
think he was only like five foot five or
something like that
and he came from a very very working
class background like i said he never
graduated high school he started working
when he was 14 and he always worked like
kind of manual labor and he so he came
across as a very like regular joe type
of dude and so a lot of people could
relate to him and i think that's why he
was probably uh really good at what he
did
now
so the thing about it though is that
because of the
violent disputes between
companies
and workers
a lot of unions at the time
even though some laws had been passed
under roosevelt that you know you
technically in some cases couldn't be
fired for trying to organize a union um
that wasn't always the way ship played
out in reality even though technically
you had the right to do that uh because
you know a lot of companies and stuff
like that would use strong arm tactics
so at this point like the unions were
kind of like well maybe we need our own
muscle we need to start doing the same
[ __ ] that they're doing
so we can kind of get uh you know get
some of what we want
so basically you know like i said there
were a lot of really bad um you know
conflicts back then where some people
got shot killed uh and whatnot
so
i think this is kind of where the
teamsters
started getting hooked up with
the mob in sorry small because it was
kind of like their hired muscle
type of [ __ ] because they knew that they
were
going into these conflicts
and that that maybe sometimes uh cops or
other like criminals or something like
that might be paid
to shoot at them or kick their asses or
whatever so they felt like they needed
something to fight back against that so
that's probably why
this whole mafia teamsters [ __ ] started
out and why jimmy hoffa came to be
associated with certain members of the
mob
you looked like you were going to say
something
yeah i was going to say um
um
david june was talking about shirts and
stuff yeah that which which reminded me
bee's nest he's got he keeps bugging me
says he wants some shirts he wants some
news designs okay want an ocp design for
you know like from robocop
easy to do all right one of those done
well let me read them
i'll shoot i'm going to shoot the screen
for it
and i want to do a canon films logo well
i still have the logo i have the logo
yeah i just haven't those would be good
sellers i think our i think i think our
subscribers would like those yeah the
canon film ones is [ __ ] universal i
think a lot of people get a 13 o'clock
labeled on the back canon films that
[ __ ] looks badass yeah yeah well like i
said it's gone yeah i have the logo i
just haven't like shot the negative we
gotta shoot it and get it done and i'll
do it
yeah place the order for it and i'll
make them i got the screens
yeah we got like a bunch of yeah we got
a bunch of yeah all right these i told
you because i told you i'd do it he's
been sending us gifts and [ __ ]
so gonna help help him out yeah i'll
send him some [ __ ]
okay so let's see where was i okay so
jimmy hoffa actually got a lot of his
experience in labor organizing from a
dude named feral dobbs um who was the
head of the minneapolis local chapter of
the teamsters and like i said this was
kind of like
um
it's basically a thing where dobbs
he was kind of like using like i said a
lot of uh the corporate the company's
tactics against them
using a lot of violence and stuff um and
he was actually able to do make a lot of
wins like in that situation so i kind of
think like i said that's why a lot of
the [ __ ] was going on at the time um you
know
so it was kind of like
like i said you kind of had to get
involved in this
that's basically what it was
so
i kind of like i gotta go to the
bathroom okay
you need to take a break huh yeah go
ahead and go to the restroom jenny yeah
go rest go go go take a bath go talk
about all right so we
said you know about this so talk about
it
all right she's gonna it looks like
grandpa's grandpa's hammer just showed
in what's up grandpa's
xanada's drinking [ __ ] kumbacha
that's there's nothing in that grapplers
so anyway she's gone she's telling me oh
man keep talking i'm gonna [ __ ] say
whatever i want to say
i think it's a good idea though to have
uh
ocp shirt near the big [ __ ] omni
consumer products from [ __ ]
uh robocop
that'd be a good good shirt
the logo is really good
and canon films is very similar
and you know i know a lot of people
[ __ ] grew up watching those [ __ ]
cheesy ass canon
canon action movies they were [ __ ]
good you know for as bad as they were
and because that studio is [ __ ]
defunct
you can just make a shirt on it you know
i think [ __ ] you guys might like that
i think she's coming back thank you here
would you rather talk about already i
was talking about the shirts
she's policing i came in and you weren't
talking here
i know i heard you
said i want to um i think those two
designs would be good i think to be very
popular canon canon and ocp
okay well i wrote it down yeah like i
said i have the canon
yeah and it's easy one color prints
but i haven't i've never done the
negative yeah yeah
that's all if i come up with something
else i'll think of it yeah
all right so
basically okay so
this is kind of like i said this is kind
of like a complicated this is just like
so much like [ __ ] complicated [ __ ]
and i'm trying to like not to lose my
place and all these [ __ ] notes but
you know how it goes
so um
so they're basically trying to
get together
all of the these kind of like disparate
unions right this is kind of where the
afl-cio came from
um you know because they're all kind of
fighting against each other different
like turf and everything like that there
was a lot of violence like i said you
know
that was going on not not only between
the companies and the unions but also
between
other you know factions of the unions
[ __ ] like that
so
basically okay
so in all this kind of like violence
that was going on
you know as the
teamsters as these unions were kind of
organizing at a national level
um jimmy hoffa he goes and uh
reaches out to this um
guy that he knew that was a friend or a
friend or a family member of one of his
former girlfriends
um
so she had married after they had dated
like when they were younger she had
married this dude named frank o'brien
now frank o'brien uh was actually a
driver for a kansas city mob boss
now frank ended up dying not too long
after you know they you know started
talking to each other i don't know how
he died i don't know if it was like he
got bumped off or he just died like
regular
but
uh frank and sylvia who was his wife's
name they had a son named chucky o'brien
now chucky o'brien would kind of become
almost kind of like jimmy hoffa's like
adopted son sort of now jimmy hoffa had
actually married
um this girl come on in
well hi she opened the door on her own
you open the door on your own good girl
good girl it's all good she's like yeah
okay
you're not trying to keep me out are you
no i'm not trying to keep you up oh
he had actually married a girl that he
had met she worked at a laundry
and um he met her during a strike like
where the laundry workers were striking
for better benefits better pay
and they kind of hit it off so they
married they had a couple of kids
but they also had this other kid like he
wasn't a kid kid but you know a little
bit older named chucky o'brien who like
i said would kind of become
um sort of like jimmy hoffa's adopted
kid and he would also kind of like
factor a lot into later [ __ ] that like
happened to him
now sylvia who was like i said jimmy
hoffa's former girlfriend and who
who he kind of first
approached and they kind of got involved
in the mob [ __ ] she actually uh after
her first husband died she ends up
getting involved with this other
gangster named frank coppola
and that was chucky's godfather
now
this dude was kind of pretty
instrumental in
really
getting the teamsters involved with like
all the mob people right he was kind of
like their the gateway the gateway drug
i guess
so basically so that was kind of like a
um
like that seven did we lose connection
it's still green
it must be if it's my tablet maybe it's
just your tablet i mean my shit's still
green uh-oh buffering somebody says
okay well hopefully it comes back my
light's still green okay just give it a
second it didn't go red
i mean it went red a little while back
so now it's showing live for me
well hopefully it comes back this is
like oh man
you're back
i shouldn't be i'm now at high speed
yeah you buffered burp for a little bit
but it's good now yeah i didn't lose my
connection but you know okay
so 1937 jimmy hoffa gets um he gets
elected to the presidency of detroit
local
299.
now he stayed president of this
um even after he got like um he was like
the leader of all pretty much all of
detroit's local chapters of the
teamsters at this point but detroit
local knight 299 was the one that he was
kind of most
associated with
um
now at this point i guess it was like
they were uh he got a draft deferment
actually for world war ii because um
they thought that he would do like he
was able to successfully argue that um
that he would be more valuable stateside
uh because he was helping run the
transportation sector so he um got off
and got to stay
here and do what he was doing
now
like i said it it seemed like after the
kind of like violence after all of the
labor unions kind of became
mob associated but it wasn't you know
they had actually gotten a lot of the
things that they wanted so it wasn't you
know so much [ __ ]
uh fighting and [ __ ] like that going on
all the time
um
basically jimmy hoffa was actually like
a pretty um
popular dude particularly in the detroit
area in the manufacturing and the
shipping sector
because
all of the
guys that got unionized under the
teamsters um their wages went like way
up uh and they got a lot more benefits
so a lot of them even later on like when
they found out like about all the mob
ties and everything they didn't really
care all that much because they were
basically like hey we're feeding our
families so it's funny hearing you
talking about the detroit area during
this era back when it worked
me and granthar's hammer who's in the
there's an ex-cop in the comment section
we grew up among the ruins of detroit
i lived on lived in second in west
hancock once i got out of damn detroit
near cass corridor for a while before i
joined the army
and it was funny because detroit looked
like beirut
a bombed out empty hulk of a city you
can or you could rent a whole building
for a couple hundred bucks
you can the goth kids had a [ __ ] ton of
fun there man at city club
and [ __ ]
the shelter
we had a good time there but it was just
funny to see
a [ __ ]
vacant city a huge metropolis just go
it's all torn down now a lot of the [ __ ]
that i remember is torn down now
the house is around it
but um
i think everybody will tell you that uh
the conduct of these labor unions had a
lot to do with the destruction of
detroit
and we went to high school with a guy
named john copera john cal perez is a
he's a big
executive in ford motor company now
he designed a lot of stuff for ford
mustang
he made the new several of the new
mustangs back when 04 came out he was
behind that
and copero man he was a [ __ ] really
good really good dude dude [ __ ]
grandparents remembers him john was the
[ __ ] there was a lot of talent in that
area
but the corruption of these dudes here
destroyed detroit they destroyed detroit
that's why movies like robocop appeared
on the back of this [ __ ]
grandpa's will tell you anyway go ahead
it's funny man the actions are just a
few dudes at the top
can create a culture of [ __ ]
corruption
that eventually can just bring an entire
city down just like roz al ghul out a
damn [ __ ] batman like this city is
too evil just
too evil and corrupt to survive it must
be brought down it's like
that's kind of what happened
and it wasn't just those riots they had
race riots and it never really recovered
but that wasn't the whole thing it was
also these unions
you just couldn't do business there they
just squeezed it and squeezed it and all
the money went away
yeah
i'm done
it just ran
well i know well i'm never sure when
you're done so
that's the way i always have to pause
now i'm just talking about what the
greatness
that was detroit
you have to you had to go there to see
it back in the day
when it was just a corpse of a city
before they tore it down
it was just magnificent it was like
urbex
urban explorers [ __ ] heaven you know
it was beautiful and abandoned just
ruins
yeah
and it was just because of the
corruption
corruption sucked all the money out of
it
globalization it all went to china
although you know
you have ford and gm still that's just
not what it was
here in this time you know what i mean
hearing about this times it was an
empire back then
looking detroit helped us win world war
ii with all those goddamn sherman tanks
they built a lot of cool [ __ ]
they were a good people
the michiganders
it's all gone no though now it's changed
well everything's changed
it's just the way of the world yeah
a lot of them moved away
so yeah so like i said we're now we're
like in the 40s 50s um you know what i
mean a lot of the truck drivers like i
said that were in the teamsters they
actually were able to get a health and
welfare fund they got like a pension
they got like better pay and [ __ ] like
that so they were very happy about that
1952 uh jimmy hoffa became one of the
teamsters national vice presidents um
the president at that time was named
dave beck
hoffa was the second in command
so at this point the teamsters moved
their headquarters to dc
and uh jimmy hoffa moved there part time
um so basically
what ended up happening uh dave beck the
president of the teamsters at that time
uh sort of got into like some legal hot
water so jimmy hoffa was kind of
essentially running the [ __ ]
uh while he was you know doing the [ __ ]
that he was doing like getting into
trouble or whatever
now
what ended up happening with beck and
they don't necessarily know if like
jimmy hoffa maybe like gave some tips to
like whoever was investigating just to
get him out of the way or if it just
happened like randomly or somebody else
had anything to do with it
um so what ends up happening with dave
beck is that
there was a committee on union
corruption
uh headed by a senator named john
mcclellan from arkansas sorry there's
like a mosquito in here or something
like that
um
so
so basically what happens they have they
start having hearings uh on this
particular issue
now
the hired counsel at the time for these
uh for these hearings was a very famous
robert f kennedy
now
this is before this is prior to uh jfk
become president obviously um you know
jfk who was robert f kennedy's older
brother uh was then a senator and he was
also on the committee
and they were kind of like looking into
like i said you know new regulations for
unions and because there was so much
corruption
now what ended up happening was that
dave beck who like i said was then the
president um he didn't do so good
like at the hearings
and um he
what ended up happening was that every
time they asked him a question he would
just basically be like take the fifth i
take the fifth on that take the fifth if
you're not from the united states taking
the fifth amendment is that's you know
um
you have the right to not incriminate
yourself so a lot of times they'll just
plead the fifth amendment saying
basically i don't want to say anything
and you can't make me so that's kind of
what he did
um and because he did that
uh didn't really
didn't really like read too well with
the public so he was kind of like um
gonna be ousted right
um he would actually eventually end up
going to jail although that would be a
few years down the line
uh at this point these hearings which i
said were very very um
i mean the public was like they were on
tv so like a lot of people were watching
them and it was like you know millions
of people were watching it so it was
kind of like a big deal like in the
media at the time
now what ended up happening too was that
because of these hearings the afl-cio
decided they wanted to kick the
teamsters out of
their uh organization that was a four to
one vote
just because they said we don't want to
be associated with all of that uh
corruption and you know the media is
kind of making a big deal but so we
don't really want to be known
now at this point
um
so jimmy hoffa because dave beck is in
such hot water he is sort of the de
facto
head of the teamsters at this point
and it seems like maybe he could have
you know
stepped forward because like i said he
was a popular uh guy who's a well-liked
dude so he could have come forward and
kind of said yeah i'm gonna like root
all the corruption out of the teamsters
and he kind of did that but it didn't i
don't know if anybody really bought it
necessarily um jimmy hoffa actually did
have to testify before the mcclellan
committee
and for whatever reason robert kennedy
really got a [ __ ] hard-on for
getting rid of this dude right it's like
they so like because remember i
mentioned earlier that robert kennedy
and jfk and jimmy hoffa were like blood
enemies
um yeah it was like it was a big deal
and i'm not entirely sure why
um jimmy hoffa did not like the kennedys
because he thought that they were
um
essentially like silver spoon
you know they they had grown up in
wealth and it's like they didn't know
because you know jimmy hoffa was like
more of a working class dude and he's
like you know you never had to work for
anything or anything like that so i
think he kind of like didn't like him
because of that because he thought they
were maybe out of touch might have been
some other reasons as well but that was
uh kind of one thing that i saw brought
up he thought they were just
privileged you know like overly
privileged and they didn't really know
how normal people lived
uh and like i said for whatever reason
robert f kennedy decided he really
really hated jimmy hoffa and he just
made it his [ __ ]
sworn mission to
put him in prison right
um you know so it's kind of like it's
it's interesting too because the
kennedys
um
were kind of like
that i mean they made most of their
money from like bootlegging right like
in prohibition
kennedy's the candidate you know
people don't like to talk about this but
you got the internet now so we can be
truthful
the whole kennedy empire was a [ __ ]
bootlegging empire they were [ __ ]
irish gangsters american irish gangsters
and there was a huge
rivalry
between the italians and the irish
gangsters when the kennedys got elected
in the presidency
the italians were like [ __ ] man the
irish now have the presidency why can't
we have it
there was some
theories that could possibly be true i
saw some of the evidence that might
might be true
that kennedy was assassinated by some
guys basically some guys the italian
mobs that were jealous
that the irish got the presidency
the irish got the presidency and bobby
kennedy the president's young son her
young younger brother
decided to go to war with the italian
mob through the criminal justice system
yeah
in new orleans
they had an italian gangster named
carlos marcellus
who was friends with an ex-cia agent i'm
forgetting his name he was a gay dude
[ __ ] bald had alopecia he was oh i
know who you're talking about yeah he
was a part of the free cuba movement
with
what's that dudes i'll probably think of
it like 15 minutes from now that dude
was friends with me harvey oswald
oswald was pissed off about the [ __ ]
bay of pigs and and the free cuba
movement
and he was there's a connection there
could have been that marcelos and this
ex-cia agent and oswald pissed off
behind two different things
oswald pissed off about the free cuba
movement in the bay of pigs and marcelos
an italian gangster who was pissed off
about
bobby kennedy said the best way to save
the italian mob is to kill jfk and that
will
disempower bobby kennedy
and they'll stop investigating the
italian mob [ __ ] them they're a gangster
family anyway
there is a good chance
that john f kennedy was killed
not by the italian mob
but with the
support of the italian mob
he was actually killed by lee harvey
oswald
but leave harvey oswald was pissed off
about the bay of pigs
and the betrayal of the cubans at the
beginning the betrayal
there's a whole book about it i read it
back in the day
called mafia
kingpin
it's either mafia kingpin or mafia
kingfish i think it's mafia kingpin
and it's about a guy named carlos
marcelos if you're interested in it read
it it's a very good book
so uh yeah the kennedys were bad
but you gotta be bad to achieve power
good people don't ever achieve power
that's why you're poor and broke when
listening to this program you're a good
person
bad people rise to the top
all you gotta do is go to the toilet and
you will see that [ __ ] floats
okay [ __ ] floats well i don't know if
that's always true yeah sure
depends on what you ate
i'm just saying the people that run the
[ __ ] in this world [ __ ] are not
trustworthy
do not trust them
they're bad santa said tom is right
about this it's been a bone of
contention for us italian americans for
a long time i'm not joking it's brought
up at family reunions
yeah
that was back before the italians were
white
now nowadays you could have an italian
president nobody would even i don't even
think anyone would know anybody notice
except maybe like super old people yeah
nobody would even know because like i
said even when i was growing up in the
70s and i read [ __ ] from the 50s where
like people were talking weird about
italians i'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with italians
what they're not white suddenly that's
weird yeah i did that
it never occurred to me in the 70s old
people would think like that but that
was like yeah that was like some [ __ ]
that my grandparents would yeah they're
all dead but i did not understand it
yeah i did not understand i'm like what
are you even talking right
and it's my prediction that hispanics
will be white people and they're white
people now i mean we [ __ ] party with
[ __ ] hispanics and forget that
they're hispanics
[Laughter]
because it's just dude i forgot you were
in space yeah well it doesn't matter we
all listen to the same music we're all
in the same [ __ ] club you know yeah
that's what i said
goth is its own i got reminded
last time i saw him you know [ __ ] up
last time that was the second the third
[ __ ]
michael was like it's so cool to be up
here in orlando and hang out with white
people
and i looked at him wait a minute you're
hispanic yeah
that's a to me you're just a person man
because miami is heavily hispanic
there's no white people there they don't
you know they don't understand us in in
miami they understand us here because
they grew up listening to
you know the kind of music that you know
[ __ ] the cure and
[ __ ] like that you know they like that
kind of music and
in general here's the thing a lot of
people think hispanics don't listen to
that
no there's a huge goth scene all
throughout central south america mexico
city like we were talking about that on
wednesday night mexico city has a map
scene
it's just
they consider it kind of like
european and northern and it's kind of
ethnically alien to them but not
spiritually i mean they got mexicans
that love morrissey that know those
lyrics and sing them in english there
are
many many many
uh mexican
morsi cover bands yeah
one of them mariachi bands that do
morrissey music mex racy yeah mexicans
are they called mexracy yeah they're
actually pretty good because there's a
terrible name but they're but it's but
they're a good band though the americas
are the americas central and south
america north america very similar
spiritually
um
the central and south americans growing
up in brazil i'll tell you man brazil
they understand the theatricality and
the emotion
of goth they understand that they're
going to reinterpret it but they know
exactly they love drama drama and
theatricality and it's right up there
man that's what guys
they understand we love that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
i don't love drama like as in like
people making drama just for the sake of
it but i'm we're talking about like
theater
drama yeah we like that we like that
thank you zach hey y'all what's up jenny
you look good with your hair down thank
you love the headband you got going to
betty page thing going
yeah yeah i just kind of just threw this
on at the last minute i didn't really
because i didn't feel like putting my
hair up and then i was just kind of like
yeah i guess it looks like it was hot so
she was put had her hair up for the last
couple shows
yeah because it's i like having it
shaved because like i said it's nice not
having all that hair under there but
today i was kind of like oh it looks
because sometimes it'll look okay like
it'll look okay down in the mirror but
then i'm
you know on camera and i'm like oh my
god that looks like [ __ ] so then i have
to like do something else with it says
italians identify as white i live in
europe travel differently yeah i know
that everybody knows this yeah but
there's something about but old america
old like grandparents or even
great-grandparents yes
right there was a thing where italians
were like considered like not like they
were non-white and like i said even i
grew up in the 70s and i thought that
was weird in the 70s
that was more like a 50s and before and
it was because and
and before the italians the irish were
non-white yeah which that's [ __ ]
weird which the irish are like
some of the whitest people
[Laughter]
but it and if you go back in history of
north america and you start reading it
it's not so much a thing of the 1700s
but a thing of the mid-1800s
there was an anglophilia
there was this there was this uh kind of
like
idealized
anglophile
ness that you had to be english
that that was the white person it was
like some hp lovecraft yeah like hp
lovecraft well he just thought you had
to be like an english person like an
upper-class english person anybody that
wasn't like an upper-class english
person then you're not even white you're
not even white yeah which is super weird
which was weird because the people that
were doing this were very were alienated
from england they were this was a
theoretical england in their mind
yeah it's like that's not who they were
no no all right
and then like h.p lovecraft never went
to [ __ ] no he didn't know nothing
about it he lived his whole pretty much
his whole life in providence rhode
island right
and then they'd look at a person of
irish descent and they'd go
you know
but the thing is
probably irish i kind of feel like i
kind of feel like even nowadays it's
probably like not as much as it was but
when i was there in the 90s i feel like
there was still a little bit of i don't
think it was like any kind of real kind
of but there was still kind of like a
little you know the irish and the welsh
like the english they don't like the
irish and the welsh like the welsh were
like sheep shaggers and yeah [ __ ] like
that they would say absolutely they were
savages and stuff but i think mostly
that was just like being funny it didn't
seem like they were really
i mean i'm sure there are some like
extremes but all that [ __ ] was
theoretical if you actually look at the
data over time
the ethnic makeup of the united states
hasn't changed that much
there's more people
but it was always about 13 black
and um
it was always about 40 percent kind of
indian hispanic or mesoamerican
and the rest of it was white and some
chinese
it's still kind of like that now you
have indian and some middle easterners
but there's not enough of them really to
make a difference
yeah i mean that's like that's a tiny
percentage
and they were thinking like this kind of
even back in the 1800s 1700s
it just it just hasn't changed as much
as people think that they're no it
really hasn't they really there has
never been as many black people as there
are now there's never been as many white
people as there are now there has never
been as many indian or native americans
or mesoamericans as there are now the
the population
everybody's population has expanded
because of technology you got
agriculture where they can feed them
and
there's also a lot of admixture but
there was a lot of admixture back then
they're not telling you about
all through the 17 and 1800s especially
during the expansion period white guys
that were moving west tended to marry
indian women
they had children
that tended to marry white people
sometimes indian people there was they
were always like some mixing there were
also black people that were doing this
marion
indians and and vice versa
so it it's always kind of looked the way
it does now just people are imagining
that it didn't
they don't know what they're talking
about they're not really looking at the
golden honky years it's like the golden
hockey yeah which never existed if you
go back to the old 50s you could go back
to the 50s hollywood [ __ ] movies
black and white movies if you actually
pay attention a lot of those people in
those 50s movies were mexican they're
mexican-americans well they just like
gave them different names
and they dyed their hair and [ __ ] like
that so they wouldn't look like that
yeah on black and white film they
wouldn't look ethnic but they were
i'm calling them looking like rita
hayworth and [ __ ] like that she was
hispanic yeah there were also like
light-skinned black people they just
dyed her hair red and gave her a
different name they're also
light-skinned black people in those
movies that [ __ ] you didn't realize
that they were light-skinned black the
actual
audience either they didn't realize that
they didn't care i don't think they
cared as much as people think that they
do now well as long as you could pass i
don't think anybody was thinking about
it as long as you seem to as long as you
spoke english and and you were dressed
right and you behaved well you were
charming i don't think they really cared
that much maybe yeah or like i said i
don't think it was anything they really
thought about them
probably
not think that much tyler the guy says
old america was weird white's racist
against what was essentially other
whites yes yes
that doesn't make any sense to me right
it wasn't
it wasn't racism it was more like
ethnocentrism yeah that's exactly what
it was it was about their
ethnic tribal identity
but their identity was anglo but they
probably weren't english
yeah they were probably german and irish
mostly there were just not that many
british people yeah
and when you look in british history
it's kind of gray who's british and who
isn't
they were because they're [ __ ] saxons
and normans and all kinds of weird
things i mean like i said you can go
back and just
every you go back far enough in time
they're all white everyone's african so
like don't worry about it uh thank you
zach
what's this here marinara sauce is that
an italian yes
yeah that was
that was something i read a book that
was written in the 50s and it was it
wasn't exactly that but it was something
like that and i just i was like what
yeah
in that cookbook that jenny and i sell
some of those dessert recipes like the
eclairs are straight from the [ __ ]
30s from a cookbook that i have a duncan
heinz cookbook
that cookbook is the [ __ ] it'll teach
you how to make mayonnaise it'll teach
you how to make ketchup all right
it'll teach you how to make just basic
components
but it has a foreign food section and in
the foreign food section
is spaghetti yeah
and it teaches you how to make spaghetti
and the sauce that's hilarious
and there's a whole segment to explain
to you what oregano is
so exotic right
and if you were to actually read what
the [ __ ] marinara sauce for that
sauce it would be terrible by today's
standards terrible
terribly terrible
spices weren't invented in the united
states until it would have been tomato
paste if all it was was tomato paste
sugar
salt
water
um
and oregano and pepper
that's it
i'm like wait a minute
where's the meat juices where's the
hamburger where's the sausage where's
the you know where's the garlic
where's the that's not not even that was
in it
so what what the [ __ ] were they doing
where's the parsley they didn't know how
to eat where yeah
back then they didn't have access to
that [ __ ] yeah no and italian food as we
know it today evolved from something a
lot more rudimentary
it was a lot more simple
the original pizza was just a round
piece of bread
with oil and vinegar on it
it had one stripe
of green which was oregano leaves
another stripe in the middle
that was sliced tomato
and another
stripe of white on the other side which
was sliced pieces of
cheese mozzarella cheese red white and
green you see the white white red white
and green
the colors of the italian flag that was
the first pizza
it was like 1920.
yeah
red white green
yeah it wasn't all together it was
separate
and i think it was offered at a an
italian at a olympic event if i remember
correctly that's where it first appeared
yeah yeah we're getting all these like
weird
it's not it's not trolls they're not
being like uh
we're getting spam yeah it's just spam
yeah get rid of the spam people
i'm done i'm working on it okay
[Laughter]
yeah it's like i don't they're not like
saying anything substantive so it's just
emotion emoticons
that's it's weird because that seems
like there's um there's been a lot of
that going on just um as
comments like on some of the um
videos like uh the recorded ones and
stuff
it's like i don't know i guess it's like
sex spots or whatever
i'm not
i think they're just passing through it
yeah probably
it's just you know this i think this
one's another one let me just see
whoops
okay i don't know
sometimes if you like do the thing and
you're not like quick enough it'll
delete some other [ __ ] that you didn't
mean to delete so if i delete anybody
accidentally
says the white birth rate will jump
between a certain amount look don't
believe any of those [ __ ] forecasts
of the future
no forecast of the future has ever ever
been correct that's why i don't bother
with it
the same demographic doom
that they predict today is the same
demographic doom the ancient romans were
predicting back during the roman empire
um birth rates have a lot to do with
[ __ ] income
people become wealthy they stopped
having as many kids because they can
professional they become professionals
but they die out and certain professions
die out and then people get poorer so
they have a little bit more children
later on
nothing is in a straight line
everything kind of goes up and down over
the centuries
i don't worry it's wavy it's very wavy
[Laughter]
the supply of people wax and wane
depending upon demand
and the way technology is now there
isn't much demand for people
so you could predict that everyone's
numbers will eventually decline
because even in india they're declining
because their standards of living are
rising
everything don't worry about it
everything works out
there will always be people i'm not
worried about no i ain't worried about
it i've never been worried about it it's
just this panicky [ __ ] there will
always be people
there will always be enough people to
meet the demand
i might need another drink might be time
for you to make me another drink give it
to me
i'm not rich so i need to have five kids
i have time
you have five kids and like put them to
work on the farm or you know sell them
for organs i don't know
i don't know
uh so yeah so where was i we got like
[ __ ] distracted again what else is
new all right so like i said we're
talking about the uh
the mcclellan hearings
so like i said now
uh what's his face uh dave beck didn't
come off too well during these hearings
like i said and you know the teamsters
were kind of like yeah we don't so much
want this dude running the [ __ ] anymore
because he just takes the fifth on
everything and like the public was like
okay well what are you up to if you like
won't say anything
so pretty much i mean jimmy hoffa had to
testify at these hearings also and he
was kind of like okay well i can't just
sit up there and like take the fifth on
everything because that didn't work out
so well for beck so
he's like basically he took the defense
where if they asked him like some shady
[ __ ] like or some sideways [ __ ] he'd
just be like well i don't really recall
that happening or you know so he would
kind of try to get around like he would
still answer the question but he
wouldn't like really answer answer the
question you know what i mean but he was
like a lot sneakier about it and
honestly i i listened to
because like i said these were all um
televised so i listened to some of the
um
some of the uh hearings and actually i
mean jimmy hoffa does actually come off
sounding like he sounds like a like a
little bit evasive but
he still sounds like he's answering the
questions kind of intelligently but not
really saying anything so he was like
pretty good at that
um so like i said you know more than a
million people
thank you more than a million people
watch these uh on tv
so
you know this was kind of like a big
deal and honestly it ended up working
out well for jimmy hoffa because um you
know he had all these politicians who
were you know clearly gunning for him
and asking him like all these really
you know asking and being like a little
bit hostile toward him i guess and he
was kind of able to deflect a lot of
their questions without looking like he
was deflecting them so i think the
public kind of
saw him as saw him in a more positive
light maybe than they saw dave beck
so uh basically kind of like um
it was kind of a thing too where
the public kind of started seeing
the uh
you know the this hearings these
hearings against the teamsters and
against jimmy hoffa like it the public
opinion started to change where now it
looked like the politicians was picking
on him um and that it was coming like a
witch hunt because like i said you kind
of had like mccarthyism and [ __ ] like
that going on too so i think a lot of
the public were kind of
turning against they're like you know
just leave the dude alone it's why you
like
being so
obnoxious because like i said uh
mccarthy was actually on the mcclellan
committee as well
so
it was you know it was kind of like a
whole thing where they just thought they
were like
picking on the dude right um so it kind
of ended up making jimmy hoffa look you
know put him in a more positive light
perhaps
grabbers your back grandpa's is back in
the conversation you missed it bro i was
talking about me and you growing up in
the wasteland of detroit and the way it
was and how that [ __ ] they they blew
the empire all that damn corruption
helped to destroy
detroit and then the unions eventually
pushed all the [ __ ] business out to
china we watched it fall
when we were kids it was already ruined
it was like some urban explorer [ __ ]
urban explorers [ __ ] dream
now it's all gone they tore the [ __ ]
down
so like i said so the public kind of had
a more positive uh view of hoffa at the
time like i said because they thought
that he was maybe being persecuted um
even though there was a lot of evidence
obviously that um that there was a lot
of corruption going on but a lot of
people didn't really see robert kennedy
in that positive light too because it
seemed like he was going out of his way
to just like persecute this one dude
like it was a personal vendetta or
something so it kind of looked like
that kind of thing although that said uh
the evidence against uh jimmy hoffa
was so good or so everyone thought that
uh bobby kennedy
said if
he gets acquitted
i'm gonna jump off the capitol doom he
basically said that
um he didn't exactly get acquitted but
it was a hung jury
so i heard that somebody sent robert
kennedy a parachute
like after that just to be like
like he didn't you know he like i said
he didn't get acquitted necessarily but
it was hung jury so it was like a
mistrial uh so jimmy hoffa kind of uh
got off on that they didn't really
conclude um you know there was really no
concrete conclusion on the matter
uh so like i said jimmy hoffa takes over
as president of the teamsters because
like i said back kind of got in trouble
um so basically it's kind of like
all right so remember i said
that you know he
jimmy hoffa was like kind of uh he was
married and he had kids and everything
and he was like a big family man and
stuff but he was also kind of like a
workaholic
um
and he
he was actually pretty good at
maintaining an image of
he didn't want to be seen as like kind
of like elite or better than anyone else
because i think that he really didn't
like that was one of the things that he
didn't like about the kennedys is
because he thought they were children of
privilege um and that they hadn't worked
for what they had and
you know they weren't like working class
so he did have like a nice house but it
wasn't like a mansion or anything and he
had like a little vacation house and
stuff but he tried and he tried to like
have an old car and [ __ ] like that he
didn't really want to like put on airs
or anything uh so like i said that was
kind of another thing that he didn't
like about the kennedys because he
thought they were
rich people who had never like lived in
the real world or anything like that now
interesting this is kind of weird i came
across this in an article
and i just i thought this was uh kind of
strange
so
basically i mean from by all accounts um
jimmy hoffa and his wife
um
were i mean they stayed married for
ages and they were apparently like very
happy together and even though jimmy
hoffa was kind of known as like this
real
um
you know
he was just kind of he was a scrapper he
would just go out there and get [ __ ]
done and everything like that and he was
kind of uh a service uh he apparently
was not like that at home
with his wife or kids [ __ ] like that um
but this is pretty weird
so at some point he's living in the
family home with his wife and kids and
remember i brought up that ex-girlfriend
of his
sylvia pagano who like had was one of
the people that like introduced him into
like the the mob life and everything
um later on she came and like lived with
them
which i thought was kind of weird now
she was the one who was the mom of
chucky o'brien
who like i said was kind of like
uh jimmy hoffa's
adopted son so some people have
speculated oh maybe he knocked sylvia up
like a long time ago and so chucky was
his actual son but i don't know if
that's true or not
but
you know i mean he was a little bit
older than the other uh than the other
kids but you know what i mean so it's
just kind of and like i said frank
o'brien chucky's dad was dead by this
point uh because he had been a driver
for like a mob boss or whatever but you
know i don't know so i just thought that
was like kind of weird that hey hey i'm
saying my ex-girlfriend is gonna like
move in with us is that cool
i don't know i just think that's so
weird but apparently it worked out okay
because i guess her and the her and the
wife jimmy hoffa's wife are friends so
you know whatever
um now interestingly in the 1960s
a lot of the uh labor unions obviously
were um
you know we're going with the uh
democrats
however uh because jimmy hoffa could not
stand the kennedys uh he was not gonna
get uh on board with that because he
really couldn't stand them so since jfk
was running for president um basically
jimmy hoff is like yeah no i'm not going
there with that [ __ ] uh so he started
working with uh richard nixon who was at
that point the vice president under
dwight eisenhower
and was also the republican nominee for
president in 1960.
now after kennedy ended up winning the
election obviously in 1961
and made robert kennedy the attorney
general
at that point because robert kennedy
still had this vendetta essentially
against jimmy hoffa he decided well now
i have like all this power behind me so
i'm gonna go after him
uh big time like they were kind of
they were kind of like uh sort of
obsessed in general with like getting
like
busting organized crime and stuff but
for some reason they really had a
particular hatred for jimmy hoffa like i
said there was a blood feud between them
yeah it was just like our italian
friends in the comment section said
it was a [ __ ]
it was it was a rivalry between
the irish and the italian mob families
also essentially that's what it boils
down to the italians got the presidency
because they were the wider of the two
group at that time so they could make
it they could pass as an anglo and then
they turned around and went and they
would [ __ ] turned on the [ __ ]
italians we're gonna wipe these [ __ ]
organized crimes to better america [ __ ]
you're an organized gangster you were
[ __ ] ramrod well that's kind of like
what gangster yeah that's what a
grandson does so all the italians were
[ __ ] who were in the know knew
exactly what this was
it was cold-blooded because i tell you
what i'm gonna be honest had the
italians got the presidency they
wouldn't have done that
they wouldn't have done that that was a
[ __ ] that was a kennedy thing
that was a kennedy thing more than
anything else
those [ __ ] spent too much time at the
goddamn [ __ ] country club at the golf
[ __ ] playing tennis and [ __ ]
chasing around
chasing around marilyn monroe
zach says we need a puppy motherfucker's
got uppity we need to do a show on nixon
watergate yeah we probably should yeah
and somebody earlier said we should do a
show on the candidate what's funny about
nixon watergate is that would be small
potatoes by today's standard nixon
watergate would be nothing compared to
what they do now they get away with it
and it never even hits the [ __ ] news
it's an it's just that it happened in a
time of american innocence i'd rather do
nixon elvis nixon elvis is more a lot
more interesting than [ __ ] although
we talked about that a lot we talked
about the movie
you have a president and a king having a
summit
that's a lot more interesting
[Laughter]
yeah camp guys talk about the there's a
movie called frost nixon which is uh
which actually
i'm pretty sure i saw in the theater
which is kind of like this really famous
uh interview that nixon did with this
british uh
tv presenter and that's that's actually
a really good movie too but yeah
elvis and nixon that was that movie with
michael shannon
and uh that child molester
kevin spacey when he a child molester i
don't know how they are yeah kevin
spacey yeah sketchy [ __ ] yeah
but look
allegedly
the irish got the presidency but the
the italians always had new york you
know they still
have new york off and on
yeah i really although i don't really
know how much like the mafia in the
sense of like the old school mafia is
still
i'm sorry they're
they're probably still around but i
don't think it's like it used to be no
it's not like it wasn't it's not like it
used to be because the italian mob all
made it
yeah they made their money then they got
into
the ultimate the ultimate goal of any
organized gangster
is
wide mainstream societal acceptance
they want to go straight
they want to be good people
that's why they that's why they made as
much money as they could as they did a
successful one is because they were
trustworthy they were good people all
you got to do is just
see cocaine cowboys on netflix right
here
right here in miami
the best guys
who made all the money were actually
nice guys they weren't bad guys
they went bad over time because they
didn't want to go to jail
but they wanted
mainstream acceptance i mean [ __ ] they
were on espn racing their [ __ ] speed
boats in public
when when the fbi was when the fbi was
looking for looking for them
and they were young they were real young
guys not the brightest [ __ ] late
teens early 20s they were making several
million dollars a month
all right that'll go to your head
quickly they were cuban guys and they
went to their [ __ ] heads you know i
mean they were but they're experiencing
the american dream from their point of
view
and that was being at your mom's house
and the mom opens up the closet
and finds millions of dollars in the
[ __ ] cash in your [ __ ] closet man
you're seven millions of dollars of cash
that was the american dream i keep
opening it but there's nothing in there
but they didn't want to be outlaws they
didn't see themselves as criminals they
are trying to actually
go mainstream
um
but that's eventually what happened to
most of the italian mob they made enough
money to where they just bought
restaurants
yeah it's like they don't have to yeah
well because the thing about it and we
kind of talked about this before when we
were talking about cocaine cowboys is
that
yeah um you know if you're able to like
make a life for yourself an organized
crime yeah the money's good but you're
uh
you're always looking at your shoulder
because you don't know when somebody's
gonna [ __ ] whack you and it's
probably the same thing in the mob i
mean it is the same thing in the mob
it's like yeah you can make a lot of
money but you don't know if like
somebody's gonna like [ __ ] roll over
on you any second or if somebody decides
they don't like you suddenly and they're
just gonna like pop you in the back of
the head one day a lot of them became
millionaires
and then took that money and then went
straight with it bought restaurants and
real estate and then you never heard
them again because then their their
children grew up straight
and then they inherited that wealth yeah
and they're just regular americans now i
mean i'd like to have millions of
dollars too but it i don't think it
would be worth it like living that way
all the time
making millions of dollars is a problem
in itself in certain ways when you don't
have any ways of explaining it because
then you're kind of afraid to buy things
you have all this money and you're
afraid to buy anything big
um because you can't explain where the
money came from it's a high stress
lifestyle even though see cocaine
cowboys on netflix that was one of the
things that explained to you that was
one of you that was one of the things
that i was listening to the mcclellan
hearings uh on youtube was that robert
kennedy kept asking like jimmy hoffa
it's like hey you have this 20 000 or
whatever amount it was it's like where'd
you get it from and like all jimmy
hopper would say i uh i acquired it or
you know yeah
he would just say i saved it he wouldn't
say like where he got it from
you know what i mean
gets to the point where you're making so
much money that there's no way to lose
money if you lose money you don't even
notice
the cocaine cowboys
would have safe houses all over a
[ __ ] city where they would take
girlfriends
so the wives didn't find out places they
could
stash cash
and product
and they would forget about cash they
would sell a [ __ ]
safe house
and then later the news and the people
would report
we found 20 million dollars in a [ __ ]
addict in this house where did this come
from
i would never i would have never
reported that [ __ ] [ __ ] no i'd be like
oh yeah for me
they were making so much that they were
forgetting about pallets of cash
oh we forgot about that pallet oh yeah
there was that there was that 20 million
dollars 20 million bucks i wondered
where that was yeah and you forgot all
about it
you know i wish that would be nice
i wish i bought a house like that and
it's nice to have so much stress on you
and so much money that you would forget
about a measly 20 million oh yeah we
forgot about that buddy yeah
well like i said i just you know i i
would like to buy a house and find 20
million dollars under the floorboards
but like i said i would absolutely not
report that no hell no [ __ ] and imagine
you find this 20 million dollars right
and then you're stressing out oh they're
gonna come back and get it
those [ __ ] they know i have it
they're gonna kill me they know i have
this goddamn money and the little do you
know there's a [ __ ] 20 year old
[ __ ] gangster who's forgotten all
about that money that's what he makes in
a week
[Laughter]
[ __ ] funny man it is yeah
your problems seems makes your money
problems seem very small when you hear
stories like that watch cocaine cowboys
it'll [ __ ] explain camp guy says just
a million or two would be enough for me
yeah same it's like that one
honestly i could easily live on a minute
those dudes would forget about where
they stashed 20 and now not notice that
it was gone
i mean because i don't know i have very
simple wants yeah to be honest with you
i don't i don't need all this [ __ ] it's
like let's go to vegas and spend a
million dollars in the casinos and like
drink champagne and with [ __ ] gold
flakes in it and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
that
crap i don't need a plane or a boat or
any kind of crap like that's ridiculous
ridiculous
is xana is telling me i need to watch
the original cocaine cow yeah that's the
same director yeah it's the same guy
well cause he started out making like
two or three documentaries before he
made like the series but they're all
like about the same thing also somebody
said that you need to watch the sopranos
which actually i need to get around to
watching that too because that's
supposedly like a really good show and i
never did get around to watching it
like i know all the plot points that
happened because just over the years
from hearing about it but i have never
seen tyler the guy says he found
something like that he'd leave it alone
he's afraid that he'd come back no i i
disagree if you found it it's because
they forgot about it
and it wasn't a big amount of money for
them that's what history says
when they would find pallets of [ __ ]
cash in florida houses up in an attic
they found it because those dudes forgot
all about it
and it was like 20 30 million dollars
but that was just nothing to them
yeah i mean if they were that concerned
about it they shouldn't everybody get it
yeah it would have never been there if
they needed it the reason why you found
it is because they didn't even know that
it existed yeah they forgot that's what
i would figure like i'm going to the
bank right now i'm putting this in my
phone it's like the myth of buried
pirates treasure
pirates did not bury treasure and if
they did bury it you wouldn't find it
because they go back there and get it
immediately
yeah they're not gonna let it sit around
if they really needed it yeah but i
researched buried pirate treasure thing
and there were people that scoffed at
that
the money was never buried
i was always divided up amongst the crew
and it was spent very quickly a lot of
it
well yeah you don't want to like keep
that much money around somebody like
swipe it off no they bought stuff with
it yeah
they bought property which is strange
but it makes sense that's not that
strange you what you're thinking of them
as savages but no they they bought
property and houses and they bought
things with it they weren't dummies they
they turned uh they turned a liquid
asset into something solid as quickly as
they could
yeah all right so let's see where was i
yeah tyler guy says kind of like how a
normal person forgets pocket chain
exactly
jeffy art says hell i'd settle for 500k
yeah me too yeah holy crap that's
probably more than that's more money
than i've ever had in my whole entire
life put together so you know
just saying
uh so yeah so
now that uh
bobby kennedy
is uh the attorney general
so he's gonna take out this vendetta
like i said under the auspices of were
going after the mob
um
but in it seemed like specifically he
wanted to go after jimmy hoffa so they
even called his uh
even called his like kind of group
uh that he created to go after them to
get hoffa squad that's what they called
it
now at this point though even though the
kennedys were like giving him [ __ ] jimmy
hoffa is still uh president of the
teamsters at this point
and he has actually gotten it up to two
million members uh by this time in the
1960s
and um because of that
uh they actually had you know you pay
your union dues so the union the
teamsters had like uh quite a bit of
money
so basically what he wanted to do um
he got like uh he was able to kind of
like negotiate national contracts for
truck drivers and [ __ ] like that
like i said he was kind of like a
well-liked well-respected
uh dude and was good at like getting
what he wanted
and so
the fact that he was uh and they know
that he was doing this like i said that
he was giving uh kickbacks
um you know lowballing contracts to
various companies um
you know people kind of knew that he was
doing that it wasn't like a big secret
or anything but because he was doing
good [ __ ] uh for the people in the union
for the workers and stuff like that
everyone just kind of
didn't really mind too much about it i
suppose uh because like i said sort of
everybody was corrupt at the time so i
feel like everybody kind of looked the
other way you know as long as the end
result was all right so it was kind of
that type of [ __ ]
now um so what happened in 1964 uh he
was actually able to bring this contract
called the national master freight
agreement and this brought about 400 000
long-haul truck drivers under a single
union contract
uh which was actually like i said was
good for those 400 000 people because
they all got like really good wages and
benefits and [ __ ] like that so like i
said he was doing some good for the
world even though everybody kind of knew
that he was
doing some shady [ __ ] on the side
now uh as i said he had been through
these hearings everyone kind of knew
there was a lot of
evidence of corruption on his part but
he had uh
you know at the first hearings he it
kind of was kind of like a mistrial so
he didn't get in trouble uh for it
at first
but
because uh robert kennedy was the
district attorney he kept like going
after them
so
or going after him rather so he had to
like spend all this money for his legal
defense um
he was kind of able to evade
legal consequences for a couple of years
but
he eventually ended up getting
prosecuted
now what ended up happening
was that
uh jimmy hoffa and some other dudes
they bought some property in florida
um which was not
ideal property maybe it was like some
hey i got some swamp land in florida to
sell you but
they said it wasn't swap land even
though we might be buying swamp land in
florida soon
we probably will be
all of florida's swampland i hate to
tell you pretty much um you know what i
mean the only reason that they like
actually built some [ __ ] on it was i
mean florida is almost all swampland
gotta tell you it's a good swamp though
it's partially you just gotta hope you
don't fall in the sinkhole it's hot or
your [ __ ] doesn't or your [ __ ] doesn't
flood real hot [ __ ] three months
three or four months out of the year
i would say more like six months out of
the year or more as soon as it gets down
below 80 i'm fine oh see i want it to go
down below 50. that would be nice and
that hardly ever happened spoiled man
i'm not idealistic [ __ ] ideally it's not
spoiled well no there is places like
that where there's weather like that
just not here
it's just not here not here
um yeah so he buys they buy some uh kind
of like shitty real estate in florida
and started selling it to union members
as like retirement properties right
um and uh the property had like even
though it was kind of crappy property
they kind of like marked it up a lot
and what jimmy hoffa was doing even
though like i said the people that were
in the union were getting their benefits
and were getting their pensions and
stuff but jimmy hoffa was kind of like
scraping some [ __ ] off the top
um
to get loans from a florida bank to
kind of get into this whole like real
estate [ __ ] that he was uh doing
what ended up happening with that was
that i guess
like investigators were looking into
that kind of [ __ ] so he was like all
right well
um
i gotta kind of like get rid of the of
this land so my name's not on anymore so
they had to like do some like shady [ __ ]
over here like some creative accounting
as they call it so they're like doing
that over here and uh this creative
accounting over here the investigators
were kind of like oh now we're doing
this over here because that's kind of
what we thought you were gonna do so
okay we're gonna look like more into
that
so
the thing too is that he was doing some
shady [ __ ] like
uh him and this other guy that was in
the teamsters had set up this
essentially a shell company that was
like a trucking company and they
registered it under their wives names
um so there wouldn't be like conflicts
of interest [ __ ] like that um and he
would do [ __ ] like like no bid contract
stuff like that so this is the kind of
like corruption that we're talking about
um so basically he started what he
started doing too
was that he started loaning out money
from the teamsters pension fund
to
mafia bosses
and they were building casinos in las
vegas yeah so jimmy hoffa's you know
funds movies about that you guys yeah
yeah it's a whole thing so like a lot of
this [ __ ] in las vegas was built off of
you know this money that he was like
funneling to that early las vegas was
yeah mafia and
but you also got to forget you you can't
forget howard hughes howard hughes was
involved in a lot of that also that too
yeah we did a show about that
but uh but yeah so he basically
because what he had done was he had
reorganized the board of directors of
the teamsters so that he kind of had
final say of like where the funds were
going like i said everybody was still
getting their pensions and [ __ ] but he
they were making so much money that he
was funneling a lot of it off to the mob
for favors and stuff you know so they
could like build casinos out in las
vegas
now what ended up happening so the shell
company that he had created uh he had
incorporated it in tennessee
so what ended up happening was that he
got charged in federal court in
nashville for this particular thing for
setting up this company
now when he was charged with this
he also
either bribed or attempted attempted to
bribe
several of the jurors
um but he hired like intermediaries to
pay them off
so um
he was hoping to like get a mistrial
because he's like look if i could just
pay one juror to be like hey yeah no
then that'll be a mistrial and that'll
give me some more time to like sort some
more [ __ ] out
um so that kind of worked for a while
uh so he got off on that thing just from
like bribing the jurors right
but then
um
another guy that he knew in the
teamsters uh who knew about the little
plan that they had
uh
kind of turned on him and started
cooperating with the federal prosecutors
uh he was given immunity
and he testified about the jury
tampering
and uh so basically robert kennedy and
his little get hoffa contingent said
woohoo we got a really solid case here
we have somebody that was in on the [ __ ]
uh and knew about the jury tampering so
they started like going after him so
they set up a new trial this time in
chattanooga instead of nashville
uh because they figured change of venue
would be better because uh nashville
they were kind of familiar with the case
so they moved to chattanooga let me
mention something okay
this is going along with the same thing
you'll find out if you read a book
called mafia kingpin that has carlos
marcelo senate and [ __ ] the whole jfk
assassination
and it kind of focuses in on new orleans
if you go to new orleans even to this
day you'll you'll sense a slight new
york accent
in that area
and it's become it's because of mafiosi
from up north in the new york area and
even detroit
were taking their money and they were
sending it down south and investing
things down south in this era
because
the south was not very well developed
you know compared to the north
and it was a lot more lackadaisical when
it came to [ __ ] laws and paperwork
so they could buy businesses it was like
a lot money laundering type of operation
and the south was a lot easier to
corrupt
they didn't ask questions they still
kind of don't
oh you got money yeah we need money here
yeah sure come here buy buy some [ __ ]
hey we're all good that's kind of the
way it was
and they're doing the same thing in this
tale
they're buying things
through tennessee
it's odd very odd but you had to
understand the united states at the time
it's not as easy to do today
but back then you can't get away with a
lot of [ __ ] that you used to be able to
get away with
back then you could take dirty money
into the south and buy something no
questions asked that's why they're doing
it
and new orleans was built that way
new orleans was always a pirate city
even way back in the 1400s before there
was a united states or before
new orleans was uh 1500 16 1600 actually
i think 16 is when it started before
there was the united states new orleans
was running strong through contraband
it was just the way it was
and that went on into the gangster era
the downtown new orleans accent has new
york in it
that's those gangsters
go ahead it's all going to say all them
gangsters gangsters
xana is saying jenny's really good at
keeping her spot in the story thank you
that's because i have notes
i have like a little thing over here
that has notes on it just sometimes i
lose my place because it just all of
it's a big wall of text so you know if
i'm drunk enough i'm just kind of like
wait where the [ __ ] was i
david june says jenny sold me as a
storyteller years ago tom grew on me now
i love him as well oh [ __ ] you dude this
channel became one of my favorites thank
you xanada uh for the super chat here's
the five good job jenny thank you thank
you very much
um david june says what i like about tom
is he it used to feel like he didn't
like the show but now he embraces it
grantham's hammer tom's three degrees of
separation to jimmy hoffa mary lynn
ricegum is in punch drunk love with
philip seymour hoffman okay phillip
seymour hoffman was incent of a woman
with al pacino god i hated that movie uh
al pacino was uh was hoffa and the
irishman okay yeah and then victor says
jenny is the best oh thank you
yeah i'm saying that because marilyn
rice goes my ex-girlfriend from high
school tyler the guy says i think it's
funny that vegas is called sin city when
new orleans exists
yeah
i i always felt like vegas felt like the
the kind of um what was that thing that
they used to sell on the infomercials
the bedazzler that's the bedazzled
version of new orleans you know what i'm
saying yeah does anybody see one new
orleans where i'm going with that new
orleans is always about women
strip clubs booze
um
gambling all your money restaurants
waking up in a pool of your own vomit
not remembering what happened yeah your
bank account has been completely cleaned
out they didn't have gambling there
all right now recently we're talking
about eight late 80s early 90s biloxi
became gambling
out of the two between new orleans and
biloxi and i lived in past christian for
a while which is outside biloxi
mississippi
um i'd take biloxi biloxi's nice our
friend moved there
um
lesbian girl uh what was her name
looking over the house
that's lesbian does not oh that doesn't
narrow it down a cute hispanic girl it
was over here at the house [ __ ] we
were great friends with a minute but
she's been gone for [ __ ] six years
now gia gia oh okay she lives in biloxi
i only say that because i knew she like
moved to new orleans like years ago and
i hadn't seen her a lot she moved to new
orleans but then she uh she likes biloxi
better so she stayed in black biloxi's a
lot is new and it's [ __ ] nice and
yeah
she was cute you guys would like gia
yeah she's rad i haven't seen her in
ages yeah although she was at a show
what like a year or two ago she was i
feel like she was in a starry night show
we saw her at will's club right because
we were like what the [ __ ] are you doing
i'll show you i'll show her gia that was
maybe like i don't think it was that
long ago was it i mean i know more like
about three years ago i know i'm getting
old and like time is going really fast
and everything but i thought it was only
like two years ago
i'm pretty sure i know it was at will's
pub i remember that so this will's pub
so it was probably a starry night show
that's gia yeah
yeah she's super cute yeah
let's wave
that lesbian girl like yeah well i'm
trying no do you know how many lesbians
yeah yeah
i'm like that's not really helping me
yeah
yeah um
here's a real good picture of gia
yeah yeah oh that's a good picture of
her actually
that's a good picture yeah
all right so
where was i everybody's talking about
how how i can keep track of my notes but
like i said i have notes but sometimes i
lose my place
okay so like i said they had an
anonymous person
uh who was supposedly in on all of this
stuff so he's like okay so he uh you
know
turns on jimmy hoff and is like yeah
i'll tell you all about this jury
tampering business
um so what happened at this trial which
was in chattanooga
was that jimmy hoffa was found guilty of
uh
jury tampering also like fraud some
other charges as well
so in 1964 jimmy hoffa actually got a
five-year sentence
oh my goodness what one more time what's
the matter she's saying one's what's up
okay oh poor baby good listen we're
talking yeah she just comes in she's
like hey
i got some [ __ ] i gotta do
she's like so weird because did i tell
you guys this she's like super into like
the closet
in my office there's nothing in there
but
for some reason she thinks there's
something super exciting in there so she
will come in here and like scratch at
the door and then like turn at me she'll
like look at me with her little face and
she'll be like maybe she wanted to go
out the back door oh poor baby yeah
she better be okay out there we'll check
on her a little bit it's only quarter
past eight here
so yeah so he ended up getting five
years uh and he did some like appeals
and [ __ ] but none of them uh worked out
so he ended up
turning himself over to state custody
and he got uh put in prison lewisburg
federer federal penitentiary
um during the time too he also got his
second conviction and that was misuse of
pension funds
uh which
he might have gotten like a 20-year
sentence although he didn't get that
much time so like i said he had a
five-year sentence and there was like
some [ __ ] added on to it
now um
it's kind of like around this time
period like i said a lot of uh they were
going after a lot of like organized
crime
uh you know leaders and [ __ ] like that
so
jimmy hoffa wasn't like the only person
to like kind of go away at this time
like as far as like gangsters were
concerned there was a lot of that [ __ ]
going around so
you know what i mean so by the time that
jimmy hoffa gets to prison
there's some other gangsters in there
that he can hang out with
so
uh one dude that he was kind of hanging
out with a little bit in prison was a
gangster named anthony provenzano better
known as tony pro
uh which is a great gangster name just
gonna say i think he had a brother named
sammy pro which i thought was very funny
too so they're the whole pros like
provenzano you wanna hear something
really funny i was like watching a
documentary about jimmy hoffa
and i think it was the buzzfeed one
because they did one about it and
somebody in the comments said every
single name in here sounds like a dish
at olive garden
they're asking me a good shirt good good
shot of the shirt somebody wants to buy
it
yeah that's it it's the tyrell shirt
it says genetic replicants
more human than human
and it says the same thing in japanese
well sort of sort of
i mean i typed it in english but in
japanese yeah
characters
yeah we try to do like the good i get
the good [ __ ] from like uh jiffy shirts
because i like the softer shirts which
are a little bit more expensive but i
like those better they're saying blade
runner just out on netflix yeah if you
guys have never seen blade runner then
there's something [ __ ] wrong with you
which version is on netflix though is it
like
one of the 50 bajillion different
versions uh yeah i like the [ __ ] new
director's cut that has the [ __ ] um
the uh
the unicorn sequences back in
that lets you know that
decker was a replicant
yeah
and the original the original story he
was a replicant
it's a lot of stuff that was cut out of
the original screenplay that you can
find even the sketches from it of what
they were gonna shoot
and i like the uh the sequel
blade runner in 2049 right excellent
movie i loved that some people were like
i don't know they don't know they don't
know blade runner lore
that same director is doing dune and
everything i heard
from
reputable people who have seen the new
dune they say it is bad ass so i can't
wait
i think it's it's going to be good i
think yeah it's going to be good the
same dude that did the new blade runner
i trust that i think he's a spanish
director he's french i think french or
smash denny villeneuve he knows he knows
the subject matter
you cannot do the dune story
in one movie
so you're not gonna see that
it's probably be two or three movies
but with dune done right it's gonna be
badass and i liked the delorentis dune
it was very rushed though you could tell
that it started to move real fast well
and even david lynch was just kind of
like man you guys are like [ __ ] with
me so much i can't do what i want to do
well it's like he didn't even want his
name on it in the end that should have
been
a uh um
a three movie set like star wars but
dilaurentis dino
dino stew man i'm getting off on dina i
love dino de laurentia studios
they had some badass [ __ ] sci-fi i
liked
um
flash gordon
conan one dune they had a lot of really
good [ __ ] they had a lot of misses too
and they were not very good with money
and that studio went under but um
dealer dino de laurentiis [ __ ] films
left us a good legacy to build on that's
just that's all i gotta say about it
yeah tyler the guy says i'm still having
trouble accepting that david lynch
directed that me too it's like it really
does not seem like a david lynch movie
at all the new ones other than kyle
mclaughlin being in it it does not seem
like a david lynch movie it's a new one
coming that's supposed to be coming out
they say is badass that is everything
star wars should have been everything
the original dunes should have been they
say it's great
and and on the back of that blade runner
prequel i'm going to say okay
i own that blade runner pretty cool it's
good it's a masterpiece
um maybe it's not what people expected
but
i was satisfied very satisfied i was too
i loved that yeah we saw it in the
theater and then we saw it again like
i've seen we've seen it a couple times
like on blu-ray it's like
some people were hell-bent on deckard as
a human
why would he be a [ __ ] human in this
story why would he and i'm not really
all that concerned over whether he's a
human or course he was a replicant
of course he was a replica
the blade runner was gaff
gaff the guy who spoke city speak the
the mexican-american guy with the blue
eyes
he was the blade runner not deckard they
had a replicant doing that job
yeah he had the technology he said why
wouldn't you yeah why wouldn't you
you think a [ __ ] a real man
is gonna [ __ ] do that job against the
little second blade no he's going to use
technology so they they use decker but
in the in the pre and in the second in
the sequel
they let you know that decker was
special though there was a reason for
him and it's because him and rachel
conceived a child which was not supposed
to happen
between
replicants
they were artificial humans they weren't
supposed to have kids
but you just got to see them who knew
who knew
you made that [ __ ] too good that's why
well
the guys should have made the lady
replicants without wounds tyrell and
[ __ ] um the dude who owned that new
company knew that
making these replicants is a waste of
time why don't you just make them
reproduce like humans and then you can
take over the earth
makes a lot more sense
yeah
because something has to dominate and
you don't want to be humans because
they're not as good as replicants
as from their point of view
they're not as good they're not as good
servants i'll agree with that yeah
all right
all right so where was i so okay so
jimmy hoff is in prison
and he's uh meets like like i said some
other gangsters so we're also happened
to be serving time uh around the same
time period including anthony provenzano
otherwise known as tony pro who was from
the geneva c crime family who like i
said
i kind of feel like maybe they were
some of the ones allegedly
don't come for me
uh hitmen
uh that maybe were behind the whole
jimmy of things i just put somebody in
time out for saying that the new blade
runner was garbage
you didn't understand the movie you're
entitlement
people cannot like movies it's not it's
okay
i mean i did love that movie though yes
i thought it was amazing
uh but yeah so uh what ended up
happening though while the two of them
were kind of like at first like buddy
buddy in prison and everything but then
uh something happened no one's entirely
sure what but
maybe jimmy hoffa was like trying to
make friends with like a rival
uh you know crime family or something
like that so him and uh tony pro had a
little bit of a falling out
uh which developed into kind of like a
grudge you know what i'm saying
so
uh you know so jimmy hoffa did his time
in prison uh was by all accounts an
exemplary prisoner didn't complain just
did whatever he was told to do just kept
his head down whatever
um now honestly what ended up happening
too was that
he got
this is how kind of popular he was he
got reelected as president of the
teamsters in 1968 while he was still
in prison
um
even though a lot of teamsters like i
said they knew that he was guilty of
corruption of the charges that had been
brought against him
but
they i mean most of the union members
were just kind of like yeah but
everybody's doing that [ __ ] so and you
know we're getting paid and we're just
so it's fine they weren't really all
that bothered about it uh so yeah they
re-elected a president even though he
was still uh in prison um he was in
prison for a while he was up for parole
a couple times but was denied even
though he was you know good behavior
so uh basically it's kind of like
so okay so because he's in prison he was
re-elected president right but obviously
he couldn't
run the [ __ ] from prison
so what he did was he appointed a friend
of his named frank fitzsimmons
to serve as acting president until he
got out
now
what ended up happening with that was
that frankfurt simmons
he said that he was going to run the
teamsters
uh as you know i'm just gonna be exactly
what jimmy hoffa would have done
um and as soon as you get out you can
have your position back i'm just like
the interim guy
uh you know
but
that's not really how the [ __ ] turned
out because it really did seem like
fitzsimmons was maybe kind of like hey
i'm kind of liking this present thing so
i'm just gonna like do this [ __ ]
so uh basically though what ended up
happening
was that
frankfurt simmons was not really
[Music]
i feel like he wasn't as well liked as
jimmy hoffa he wasn't maybe as
experienced in or he wasn't as good at
kind of getting everybody on the same
page
as jimmy hoffa was
um he wasn't that skilled of a leader
so
what he ended what fitzsimmons ended up
doing which is something that jimmy
hoffa would not have done was
fitzsimmons decided he was going to give
more power back to
the
leaders of the locals
now
i mean on paper maybe this sounds like a
good thing but
all it did really was like give more
power to like kind of smaller fifedoms
and then they all started like
infighting whereas when jimmy hoffa was
running the [ __ ] it was more like
centralized and everyone was kind of
getting along better so
the fact that they kind of decentralized
the power didn't work as well as maybe
you would think it might
uh so you know and the thing about it
too was that
so what ends up happening is that all of
these smaller
they you know they didn't really have
the power of like this national thing
like backing them now because now
they're all like more localized and it
was easier for local
mobs local gangsters to take over
the smaller you know locals
uh which wasn't like i said which wasn't
something jimmy hoffa would have been
happy with
now
what ended up happening too was that
while fitzsimmons was running the [ __ ]
he would um
something that fitzsimmons would would
have done that probably jimmy hoffa
wouldn't have
uh you know was that he would send like
thugs to go around to like local
businesses
and
get protection payments so he was doing
like mob type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
um
[Music]
he would go and get protection
payments
to let the company remain
non-union like so he was essentially
yeah so he's like going around with
thugs saying you know give us some money
and like we'll keep a union out of your
[ __ ]
type of thing which like i said was not
something that jimmy hoffa would have
done because he was you know as much as
he engaged in gangster-like tactics he
did actually seem to believe in
you know letting like working people in
the unions like believed in their cause
so he wouldn't have
essentially like bribed companies into
like saying hey we'll keep unions out of
here if you
you know give give us these payments or
whatever so it was kind of like that
kind of [ __ ] so frankfurt simmons
he um
eventually ended up he's like basically
what he wanted to do even though him and
jimmy hoffa were at some point were
friends
he's like well
uh i decided that
even though i told jimmy hoffa that as
soon as he got out of prison thank you
john robertson love your podcast i
heavily identify with a lot of what tom
says about south mississippi me being
from arkansas thank you jenny for
inspiring me to become an amateur horror
writer well awesome thank you very much
you kind of get on that man a lot of
good writers from the south man
david jim tom you wouldn't block me you
love me yeah
stop [ __ ] around and now i'll block a
[ __ ] [ __ ] at random well i'm
the drunker
[ __ ] he probably blocked me i will
block an innocent [ __ ] punishing
the guilty anybody can do that
innocent
do not [ __ ] with me
i'm not i'm in this state no not when
he's in this state
yeah you don't want her now you don't
want to
but sam was talking about she really
couldn't make it to conan 30 minutes out
and she was like you got to see conan
conan jeremiah johnson
[ __ ] apocalypse now john milius was
involved in all that [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
high testosterone stuff
but it is allegory conan is allegory
it's epic storytelling just conan one
not conan two uh conan one yeah conan
two was a little laurent yeah
it's okay but
it could have been a lot better conan
one
is prehistoric star wars
all right just keep watching it just
watch the and you have to be in the epic
mood
it kind of unfolds slowly at the
beginning
but it's cool you just gotta let it go
you will like it when valeria probably
shows up that's conan's girl girlfriend
but they're like partners in crime
they're both thieves they're stealing
[ __ ] from an evil cult
so it's okay yeah it's got it's got uh
james earl jones in it plays dulce dew
with a snakehead yeah well part of the
time and it's uh dulce doom and his cult
are kind of like an allegory for [ __ ]
communism probably marcus marxism
john milius was a [ __ ] strong strong
anti-communist he didn't like
um
he also did apocalypse now there's a
there's a lot of [ __ ] parallels
between conan and apocalypse now they
have the same ending actually but go
ahead
okay so at this point uh frankfurt
simmons like i said has decided hey i
kind of like being uh president of the
teamsters even though i told jimmy hoffa
that when he got out of prison i was
gonna let him have the [ __ ] back because
i'm only the interim present but
in the end like [ __ ] him i'm gonna like
[ __ ] do what i want
so what he ends up doing
um obviously the teamsters had not
endorsed uh nixon running for president
in 1968
but
uh they decided to do so in 1972 and
they gave a contribution to his
committee to reelect the president
or creep as it's known which always
makes me laugh every single time i read
it uh they might have given him a
million dollars allegedly uh they're no
one's entirely sure
um but one of their conditions was they
said okay um
nixon
had to commute jimmy hoffa's sentence uh
they basically wanted him let out
but a stipulation that they added on to
that with frank fitzsimmons alleged uh
insistence
was that well you can let him out we'll
give you all this money but you have to
say that he's not allowed
to engage in direct or indirect
management of any labor organization
until 1980 that's the year that his
prison sentence would have ended
so they're basically like
tying his hands uh they're getting him
let out so it looks like he's the good
guy but they're also adding the
stipulation that he can't do any labor
organizing until he would have got out
of prison anyway
uh and that was like frankfurt simmons
wanted to like move in on the [ __ ] on
his territory right
so december 1971 jimmy hoffa gets uh let
out
so he gets let out of prison he goes
back to michigan uh and reunites with
his family they were obviously very
happy to see him his wife was like
thanking nixon for letting him out and
everything
but as soon as jimmy hoffa found out
that one of the conditions of him being
led out of prison was that he wasn't
allowed to engage in any type of union
activity uh whatsoever until 1980 he was
pissed off uh because they didn't tell
him this before they let him out
so uh so yeah so he got out he was like
really really mad about it and then he's
kind of like
look he's like if i had known that this
was how it was going to go down i would
have just stayed in prison like and done
out the rest of my sentence because this
is some [ __ ]
so he actually tried to sue the
government claiming that this
restriction on his movements was
unconstitutional
um but it didn't really uh go so well so
what he decided to do uh he goes back to
his uh you know his regular his detroit
local 299 and he goes and just starts
working there like low level figuring
well i'm just gonna like work my way
back up uh because technically i'm not
like an organizer i'm just like working
at the thing so he was like doing that
now uh so essentially what happened was
that
after nixon ended up resigning in 1974
because of the whole watergate [ __ ]
um jimmy hoffa said okay well maybe uh
now that gerald ford is in maybe i'll
get the restrictions lifted and i'll be
able to like go back to my regular job
again
but in 1974 the district court in dc uh
said that no the stipulations uh were
the president is perfectly within his
powers to like say that you can't do
that [ __ ] it's not unconstitutional so
um you know because his crimes had been
tied to the leadership of the teamsters
they actually allowed the um you know
the conditions to stand so he was not
allowed to go back to doing what he was
doing
now apparently what happened here since
frankfurt simmons was still uh the head
of the teamsters at this point because
like i said jimmy hoffa was out of
prison but he was not allowed to come
back and work for them anymore because
of the conditions of his release
um the thing about the mob was that they
were way more into like frank
fitzsimmons being the head of the
teamsters because he was a lot uh easier
to work with in that he would pretty
much do whatever they said whereas jimmy
hoffa not so much he was more like you
know contentious toward them and [ __ ]
like that so they liked having someone i
guess more pliable uh at the wheel
and uh so you know they weren't really
uh
the mob were not all that keen on having
jimmy hoffa come back and be like the
head of the teamsters again because he
was
too hard for them to work with because
like i said he he was only using them
for his own ends he wouldn't like
necessarily do whatever they said and
they didn't really like that
so what they thought too was that
because jimmy hoffa was so popular
that if he did come back that there
might be all of these new conflicts like
among the crime families among the
different teamsters there might be a lot
of these different feuds among the
different factions
and that might uh turn into like a
nationwide [ __ ] type of thing
at this point we have a dude named
russell buffalino who was called the
silent don
now he was the head of the philadelphia
mafia
and uh he apparently was kind of like he
was kind of coming into the scene and he
was
kind of telling jimmy hoffa hey like
shut your face and just like you know
sit in the back of the room and let
everybody because nobody like wants your
involvement anymore uh because your
presence is getting to be a nuisance so
like i said this is kind of why i'm
thinking
that at this point they had him like
whacked
now
jimmy hoffa perhaps to his either credit
or
something
he was not gonna let the mob tell him to
sit down and shut up he was pissed off
about
the conditions of his release he was
pissed off about the mob telling him to
shut the [ __ ] up
so he was just gonna go right out there
and like [ __ ] you know uh what he
started doing was he started going out
essentially in public and saying hey my
ex-friend frank fitzsimmons who i put in
the president's position while i was in
prison thinking he was my friend um i'm
gonna come out and expose him and all of
his mob connections
uh and that kind of would have put a lot
of
people
in real uncomfortable
positions uh and it's
like i said i don't know if that's a
credit or a detriment because jimmy
hoffa had some mob ties himself so
coming out
publicly
and exposing all this stuff would have
also exposed him as well
but maybe he was too pissed off to care
at this point i'm not really sure
um so
at this point uh it's late 1974
and allegedly no one is sure thank you
victor this is the second time i've ever
drank during the show i'm usually at
work oh
only the second time wow
that's awesome that's awesome
yeah we're drinking too
there's a conversation going on in there
between sandra and all the other little
heavy hitters about conan apocalypse now
and jeremiah johnson it's all going on
people's lists
yeah they are all kind of the same story
they're all conan stories
jeremiah johnson is the american conan
[ __ ]
apocalypse now was the vietnam us army
conan
conan was conan
it is
they were all
kind of allegories
and lessons on self
building
and also masculinity
and what it means to be a man
but in conan also what it means to be a
woman
uh and it's it's philosophy
nichian germanics sandra you will like
it that's some germanic [ __ ]
it is idealized
but it's also mythology
okay and that's in all those stories
jeremiah johnson was mythological there
was a man like that but those are just
tales that he told
he probably didn't do half or one
quarter of what they said he did
conan is the same way that was made by a
texan crazy ass texan [ __ ] what was
his name [ __ ]
howard robert e howard
and that was it was idealized to
masculinity
nowadays they probably call that [ __ ]
toxic masculinity but it's not toxic it
is a creative masculinity it's about
defense defending and growth
and how women play in with this and
reproduction and
and what it means to be friends and what
what [ __ ] a bromance is all that
shit's in these movies and all of them
because that's
john millius wrote and or directed all
those and milius was the [ __ ]
amelias was also [ __ ] kind of like
and sometimes kind of loved and
lampooned in hollywood for his
beliefs um but
directors other directors did respect
him you know he did red dawn also uh but
they did respect him he was he was a
good dude and he was a big talker what
was the great about big lebowski
in the big lebowski they [ __ ] had a
character who was supposed to be john
bilius yeah it was based on him but
that's what i've heard yesterday john
goodman's john goodman's character
shut the [ __ ] up donnie yeah just the
[ __ ] could have done it he was just kind
of a man's man kind of a he was a jewish
dude in hollywood
who was right wing kind of an aerial
sharon type guy big into stuff that
other jewish dudes like
spielberg and lucas wearing it they
weren't into that like that's kind of
fascinating he's like oh [ __ ] you you're
not a man dude he was that kind of guy
you know but he was he knew he was
talking about just another approach
another angle
of it
i believe it all these different
viewpoints should be shown i like them
all they all have their strengths and
weaknesses
but a lot of these out of the directors
the classic directors of that era milius
john milius was my man that was the
ariel sharon of [ __ ] of directors i
liked him
david june says is it better than the
shining trick question hardly anything
is better this is what better than the
shiny i don't know i don't know conan
probably
sandra said when tom talks about it it
sounds awesome tom's descriptions are
better than the movie no [ __ ] no
apocalypse now is one of the best movies
ever [ __ ] made
apocalypse now is one of the best movies
ever made
it's just that it's a war movie
some women aren't into that conan is
also kind of like a war movie it
involves cults in a [ __ ] another age
and she likes jeremiah johnson
sandra like jeremiah is this they're all
kind of the same story in a way
they're just in a different setting
[Music]
said every two or three years the fbi
digs up a horse farm or woodlot in
suburban detroit based on tip yeah and i
kind of saw i was watching a documentary
about it where they
dug up some horse farm
and then they dug in one place and
they're like yeah we didn't find [ __ ] he
was supposed to be like in a [ __ ]
barrel or something and then like uh
this one dude comes on and it's like
yeah well they had the map upside down
or something like that and they were
supposed to be like digging over here
and they'd decorate i don't know i kind
of feel like like i said if it was the
mob you'd think they'd have better ways
of getting rid of somebody than just
like putting them in an oil drum and
burying them
i kind of feel like why don't they throw
them in a wood chipper or something i
don't know but whatever so uh so yeah so
we're talking about uh russell buffalino
um and
allegedly like i said um he kind of like
warned uh jimmy hoffa a few times it's
like hey shut the [ __ ] up sat the [ __ ]
down um he was too much of a
troublemaker like i said they liked
fit simmons being in charge of the
teamsters because he was a lot easier to
work with from the mob point of view um
jimmy hoffa was more of like i said a
troublemaker
so basically uh jimmy hoffa perhaps to
his uh you know or perhaps unwisely
decided he was gonna get like all
[ __ ] pissed off about it so
he starts saying yeah well i'm gonna um
you know go to the feds and tell like
fitzsimmons and talk about fitzsimmons
mob ties and like expose everybody
at which point allegedly russell
buffalino maybe uh maybe authorized a
hit on him
um
with anthony provenzano also known as
tony pro
he was the one that was supposed to do
it
like i said nobody knows if this is
entirely true or not because everybody
tells a different story
but allegedly
july 1975
jimmy hoffa gets an invitation
uh from a dude who was a mobster in
detroit named anthony tony jack
giacoloni
and he's like okay we're gonna have like
this meeting with tony tonypro
uh cause we know you guys are beefing so
we're gonna sit down to have a meeting
and we're gonna work everything out
so they schedule this meeting
now at this point jimmy hoffa has got to
be thinking
probably
this is not like i'm probably like my
ass is in danger here i would think like
he wasn't a stupid dude you would think
that he kind of knew what was going on
um now at this point like i said if
you've seen the movie the irishman which
most people that i saw like talking
about this in documentaries writing
about this and various things think that
frank sheeran otherwise known as the
irishman
is full of [ __ ] that he wasn't the one
that did this but
according to his account uh he was a
friend of jimmy hoffa's he was
led the teamsters in del he had a
local in delaware
and he was supposedly i don't know if
this is true or not but he was
supposedly a hitman like kind of on the
side that was like a side gig
um
so supposedly he was going to be along
as like protection like jimmy was going
to bring him along
as protection
so what happened
uh jimmy hoffa writes a note
um
and leaves it at his vacation house at
lake orion
now this note says that he is supposed
to go for this meeting at 2 p.m
on july 30th at a restaurant like called
the maccas the maccas red fox this was
in
bloomfield township which is a
suburb of detroit
now
what they were supposed to do i don't
know if they were like supposed to like
meet in the restaurant i think they were
just gonna use the parking lot and then
they were gonna go somewhere else
like somewhere non-public so they could
like talk
about [ __ ] and not be like monitored
so apparently what hath what happens is
that
jimmy hoffa is driving from his lake
house on lake orion and he's trying to
get hold of this other dude named uh
louis
linton who was also maybe kind of like a
muscle type of dude so he apparently
tried to get in touch with that dude but
he couldn't get in touch with him
so
he ends up going to this meeting
by himself
so he gets to this restaurant
and he goes to a pay phone uh at 2 15
and he's basically like look i was
supposed to meet these dudes at 2
o'clock um tony jack and tony pro
he was supposed to meet them at 2 15.
he's like these [ __ ] haven't shown up
yet um just sitting here waiting
and he tells her
that i'll be back at the lake house at
four o'clock
so apparently he was waiting there for
an hour and a half and nobody turned up
um now at this point
uh so nobody comes there like so he's
supposed to meet somebody at two but
nobody shows up
so according to several witnesses jimmy
hoffa just went into the restaurant ate
some lunch and then came back out and
then he was waiting more in the parking
lot
and then he goes back in and makes a
phone call to uh louis linto from a pay
phone in the basement
and this is the last record they have of
him um several people said that about 3
30 p.m they saw like a burgundy colored
sort of like mercury marquis i think it
was
showing up in the parking lot and maybe
he got in the car with like two or three
other people and then it drove off
but essentially that's like the last
time that he was ever seen alive
so he doesn't come back home that
evening his wife starts freaking out as
she would
uh the morning after that she calls her
kids and tells them hey
your dad never came home
his daughter barbara was in st louis as
she flew back to detroit at the time
now she was pretty sure
that
i mean everybody's pretty sure that he
got murdered like i said
um
the only question is
who did it and where he ended up
um
i think for a little while because i saw
some like um some footage at the time of
like his son and his daughter
and they were kind of like saying hey if
you've kidnapped our dad like for ransom
or something like that like please
please bring him back and all this other
kind of [ __ ] but
his daughter says at least she said
later that when she was um
coming to detroit after she heard that
her dad hadn't come home she was pretty
sure that he had been
murdered
so
investigators start
they're pretty sure early on that yeah
he probably got whacked so they start
looking for his body uh which
if you know anything about the jimmy
hoffa case
they never define that [ __ ] they're
still every now and then
are still like kind of
following up some tips looking for the
[ __ ]
um yeah so i think somebody brought this
up earlier probably the most common myth
this is the one that i always heard
growing up was that jimmy hoffa was
buried beneath giant stadium in new
jersey which at the time of his
disappearance was actually being built
uh so basically like the the new jersey
mob it's like they bumped them off and
then they just poured them in the thing
and then concrete was poured over them
so they'll never flank find it
um now that giant stadium was torn down
actually in 2010 uh but obviously they
never never found anybody's in there
because i don't really think that's what
happened
uh some other people said that he that
his body got taken to new jersey
and dumped in a landfill that was
supposedly like a big uh
mafia
body dumping
area because like i said that was kind
of like a thing like the mob a lot of
people that were in the mob
own [ __ ] like
landfills sanitation type of facilities
funeral homes that kind of stuff which
if you think about it that's like a
really good thing to own if you really
have a lot of bodies you need to dispose
of thank you david june make me a drink
tom
yeah i'm drinking [ __ ] apple pie
right now is it
yeah
cake flavored vodka and apple juice it
tastes just like apple pie try it
try it try this in my face just like
apple pie
strong too
that's pretty good i don't it doesn't
taste like apple pie it tastes like um
more like apple
what is that i've tasted it like a bear
claw like an apple yeah yeah yeah what
do they call that thing like an apple
fritter apple fritter it kind of tastes
like an apple fritter yeah it's very
sweet though i don't think i could drink
a whole thing of that as drunk as i am i
can continue to drink well i'm
convincing sandra to watch to watch
[ __ ] conan she like jeremiah johnson
yeah
yeah you would like you would like conan
and you'd like apocalypse now is
actually the best out of all three
yeah i would agree with that yeah that
is the shining of war movies it's good
really good but
watch conan conan is like an opera it's
like a germanic opera it's like the
nibelung
it's mostly music and score and
friendship and fighting some stuff and
some some
allegories for life's lessons
and when you get done watching it if you
don't if you don't understand it all i
did we did a whole show on what all that
stuff meant
men stealing the power of women for
their own power yeah
people all this kind of [ __ ] that they
do yeah it's all in there that's taking
my power that cult was doing that
seducing women and the through the power
of the feminine to empower themselves to
fool the women to cause everyone in a
circle jerk to eat each other so they
could have power they weren't producing
anything so they had to resort to
cannibalism
it's it's a good it's a good allegory
for things
i don't know why but that just reminded
me of this i was watching some like uh
old hotel hell on tubie last night and
every time there was a commercial break
there's a commercial on there for what's
it called sexy it's like a birth control
yeah foam or gel or something
and
the whole premise of the commercial
is that a woman
i'm not really entirely sure what the
logistics of this are but it's a woman
who is like living inside her own vagina
yeah yeah we saw that commercial and
every like at the beginning of the
commercials chicks [ __ ] it looks like a
[ __ ] welcome to my vagina as she says
yeah and i'm going like and like the
inside it's like all carpeted and like
pink and stuff i'm like man it's like
the top of the sands hotel that's pretty
awesome like [ __ ] i wanna rent that
route i'd be teaching that [ __ ]
and she's going to be in the [ __ ] with
me i can't understand it how does that
work so she's listening
we're talking i'm in the pool yeah well
that's what i'm saying but
honestly that's a pretty successful
commercial though because it's like one
it made me like laugh out loud every
time i saw it yeah i was drinking at the
time [ __ ] jenny's going we're in her
[ __ ] and she's talking yeah i was like
dude we're in here i'm gonna have to
shake myself what we're in her [ __ ]
she's like yeah we're in our posting
yeah she's talking like so we're in her
[ __ ] right now and it's all [ __ ] red
[ __ ] pink and [ __ ]
background it looks like inside of a
hotel i was like wow inside of my vagina
was that fancy well i had to stop myself
i would want to like run and live in
there too yeah i'm like i'm like jenny
i'm going to live
inside the interior of her body yeah
yeah she's in her own [ __ ] telling us
so this yeah i was like don't ask me how
it works it was like all meta i was like
it's a funny commercial
so kudos to whoever came up with that
concept because i was just kind of like
all right i see where you're going with
that i like it i like it but yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know why that just reminded me
of that because you were talking about
like dudes stealing like women's power
and stuff and i was like oh like that
woman that lives in her vagina
the woman that lives in her own vagina
oh that's the story prompt i should
write a story about a woman that lives
in a room vagina that would be a pretty
good story all right so um
yeah so this whole landfill thing like
they dumped him in a landfill uh the
landfill that they supposedly dumped him
in that has been searched but they
didn't find any human reins there so
probably not
um
now some other uh theories say that he
was buried in shallow grave near the
murder site uh yeah we're gonna go back
and move the body later but they never
got around to it
um
i kind of don't buy that either because
like i said this is the mob
uh body disposal was kind of one of
their things
so if they were gonna do it they would
do it in a way where like the [ __ ]
wouldn't be found which obviously they
did in this situation because he hasn't
been found i don't think there's
anything left and like you said
there was one theory this is this is the
theory you would adhere to right where
he was just put
in a car yeah and then it was granted
your grandpa's hammer said the same
thing even before he spoiled the [ __ ]
before the show even started but i
believe he's right
you have to understand that this is an
industrial city
heavily heavily linked with the
automotive industry
and in the detroit area there's a bunch
of scrap yards
and the mob had friends working in all
those goddamn scrapyards there's no
reason to bury anybody there's no reason
to do all this [ __ ] weird [ __ ] like
grandpa's talking about feeding people
to pigs there's no reason for that in
detroit
especially when you have so much power
within the audio industry and all the
all the [ __ ] industries that are
surrounded
hoffa was disposed at an industrial
level
you take him and you do what you always
do when you get rid of a body you put it
in the goddamn trunk that's step one
then you take the car you say well we're
going to put him not only in my car
we're going to put this [ __ ] in
a junk car
and we're going to take him down to
scrap yard where our friends on duty
right now and we're going to squish and
we're going to have this car crushed
so you put them in there and what they
do is they [ __ ] crush him
crush the car into a cube a couple feet
on the side
and then they take that cube and they
throw it into a pit of [ __ ] molten
[ __ ] metal
to reclaim all that metal
that's what that's what i believe is
most plausible based on everything that
all the evidence that we have that's
what happened to hoffa
he was vaporized in molten metal
well they have had some other i can't
remember who it was that said it but one
of the gangsters that supposedly knew
what was going on said uh he's part of a
japanese car right yeah he's part of a
japanese car right now
i don't know about it now but back then
because
with a system like that the dudes
running
the scrap yard would would not even know
what the hell was going on it's just
that a gangster friend of theirs said
crush that car
never okay
yes sir they don't know what's in the
damn trunk well they're not going to ask
questions all right because they're
going to get gangsters they're all
friends and [ __ ] these are all friends
okay yeah fine
they're not putting two to two about
this and that they're not gonna rat
anyway and then when they're crushing
that car they're handing out hundred
dollar bills to everybody
that's what happened
whatever
biological material was in that damn
trunk was crushed down to a tiny space
it hit that molten metal was vaporized
that seems like the best way to do it i
mean like i said you know we're talking
about the movie the irishman and i'm
pretty sure and this is another theory
that was going around the time i'm
pretty sure that this is what they uh
portrayed in the irishman was that
uh they just shot him in the head
like he got in the car they took him to
a house they shot him in the head and
then they took him to a crematorium
that one of them owned or like was owned
by a friend of theirs and they just
threw him in the [ __ ] uh crematorium
the crematorium would still have bones
and [ __ ] well yeah that would work
too but it's kind of like well you know
and you're calling attention you're now
going to place where they're yeah i
believe and i believe i'm agreeing with
granters based on the the detroit
solution to this problem for these
[ __ ] here would have been to
scrap the car
just put him in a car and scrap the car
beowulf said that's how christine was
made yeah i kind of that's maybe what
that's the first thing i thought of like
at the end of christine where they
crushed her into like a cube back in the
heyday of detroit those scrap yards ran
24 7. there's no reason to even [ __ ]
no one would even notice probably just
show up and go scrap this car for us
okay
yes sir there it is like i said no one
would even think about it i mean they
might think about it but what like yeah
they don't know that is right
so i don't know that does seem like kind
of like there would have been nothing
left yeah and then there's none of this
reason none of us worry about well where
is his body wherever is he buried well
like i said the best way to avoid that
is to like make sure that there isn't
there is no body
like pour it in the acid plate please go
down to the bottom of there's something
you could go down to the bottom of that
feed it to a shark you could go down to
the bottom of that molten slag and look
all you wanted and you'd never find a
body that [ __ ] was reduced to smoke
along with the plastic and all the other
[ __ ] that was in that car
yeah i mean like i said that seems like
that would be probably the best that
that would be like yeah yeah
that'd be the first thing you'd go to
because they had access to that
technology so that would be just the
first [ __ ] no-brainer
put him in a trunk and crush the car
have it [ __ ] send it to the scrap
yard yeah that's a
so yeah so he disappeared in 1975
uh seven years later uh july 1982 he was
officially declared dead because like i
said they have no idea where he went uh
murder case remains open
but
inactive
as they call it now
now one of the first biographies of
jimmy hoffa after he was
after he disappeared let's let's be
honest he was murdered uh this dude
named dan maldea
he uh did a lot of research and talked
to a lot of different gangsters that
would have known what was going on and
he thought
that maybe
his theory was because like i said i i
kind of feel like this came back into
like the public consciousness because of
the martin scorsese move the irishman
which was about frank sheeran who
that whole story about him like yeah we
picked him up in this uh car and like we
took him to this house and shot him like
i said the fbi actually did investigate
the house that frank sheridan said they
did find blood there
but they were unable to match the blood
i've seen like some sources say it
wasn't
uh jimmy hoffa's blood and some saying
like the results were inconclusive like
they couldn't tell whether it was jimmy
hopper's blood or not they did find
blood in the house that frank sheeran
said that they'd shot him in but
that doesn't necessarily mean that's
where they shot him my boy granters we
went to high school together he's ex-cop
in case you guys are just jumping in the
show he [ __ ] knows detroit real well
we both [ __ ] came up there
um he said minnie a body has quote
disappeared in the detroit scrap yards
yes
it's another place it is a very
industrial place especially back in
those times all the equipment and
technology was there they would not do
anything
out of the ordinary or crazy they would
go right to the [ __ ] easiest way to
dispose a body they had it
they had
[ __ ]
connections with all those scrap yards
they just would have put him in a trunk
and [ __ ] said scrap that car and
that's what would have happened
you never would have found that dude
and he wasn't the only one [ __ ]
grandpa's right he probably did that
regularly on a regular basis to other
dudes they wouldn't done anything
special
why bury it dude because then you're
worried about [ __ ] somebody digging
them up and then that's work
scrap the [ __ ] car
panthers hammer points out uh dig up any
detroit house floor and there will be
dry blood exactly and that's why they
couldn't say
you know yeah that's where he was killed
because they're like yeah there's blood
there but it's like that could be
anybody's yeah that could be anything
who knows who was murdered in this
[ __ ] house but uh yeah so dan muldale
like i said he was a biographer
his story was he didn't think that frank
sheeran
was the dude that killed jimmy hoffa
because like i said that was kind of the
basis of the whole movie the irishman
because frank sheeran
on his deathbed that was his deathbed
confession that he said he killed him
most people think that he was full of
[ __ ] that he wasn't they're they're not
saying he wasn't there or he didn't know
about it but they don't think that he
was the actual one that did it
um so what this particular dude thinks
he says that 3 30 p.m like i said um
jimmy hoffaad showed up in at this
restaurant parking lot because he was
supposed to meet these uh tony pro and
uh the other gangster dude at uh this
restaurant and they didn't show up and
he waited there for like 90 minutes
and then so chucky o'brien like i said
who was kind of like his foster son
right shows up in the parking lot um in
this mercury marquee
in the car also with salvatore bergoglio
who was kind of like this other gangster
now
this particular biographer thinks that
actually it was salvatore bregulio who
was the dude that actually killed jimmy
hoffa
but no one will ever know because that
dude was murdered only three years later
so you know
um nobody knows if that's uh who it was
or not
now
he seems to think uh this particular
biographer damn well dale like i said
seems to believe
that chucky o'brien who like i said was
kind of like a son to jimmy hoffa wasn't
really didn't really know that this was
going to be a hit
they just invited him along like you
said because they didn't think that
they thought that jimmy hoffa would be
suspicious if like just these other
gangster people showed up it's like oh
my god they're gonna like [ __ ] whack
me
but if chucky was there like maybe he'd
be like okay i'll get in the car because
everything is legit you know what i mean
which like i said that sounds like some
[ __ ] they would do
oh hold on sandra jumps in he goes
detroit sounds like hell i have to
google the pictures
look
robocop was based upon detroit as it was
disintegrating a lot of the detroit
downtown area had the the robocop
ocp
omnis consumer products feel
it was the american version of siberia
like tenkel grad where they made all the
tanks
you know [ __ ] like that
but that was just downtown the place
where me and granters [ __ ] were
growing up in high school but i it was
also brazil for me too i'd switch
between the two at that time
was actually very positive
uh and it had a lot of promise for the
future
it felt like
hilldale
from the back to the future [ __ ]
movies that's that it was like all
american
mom apple pie chevrolet
very american very [ __ ] michael j fox
that's kind of how it felt bob seeger
um
hey get a job with the company be a
company man you'll make money everything
will be great you'll have a big house
rotating credit you have a bunch of
credit cards you'll have any kind of car
you want your car will have a turbo
charger on it you'll be able to [ __ ]
get a blonde wife with a [ __ ]
redheaded girlfriend it [ __ ] won't
matter it's just
endless growth
tomorrow is a utopia that's an
industrial utopia that's the way it felt
connor before
before all that [ __ ] got shipped out to
china
because uh that's it was very very
positive
in the suburb in the suburban areas at
least where we were in trenton
it didn't last though [ __ ] um
yeah the american dream
kind of falling apart
i don't think it was ever really a thing
well when you were a kid you thought it
was
yeah but that doesn't mean it was really
a thing but it meant you were a dumbass
kid that believed no but your parents
that's the way it was for them
sorry and for their parents it was the
way no panthers tell her
they all were why are you acting like
i'm not the same age as you no i
remember but it was that area
that area around detroit no it was super
[ __ ] positive
and
every time you went back a generation it
was more and more positive because they
they all
kind of had it made
yeah well you have to think too that
back in the day people had a lot lower
expectations no also no
no no they they had it made they were
they were doing very well very well they
were all in those unions they were
making a [ __ ] ton of money
they were moving up and buying big
houses they they own things it's just
that it it kind of hit a bubble
and politics and the unions [ __ ]
destroyed all that [ __ ] and they shipped
it overseas we were kind of me and
granters were growing up in the time
where they were just starting to ship it
overseas
a couple years later i left
uh what was that i guess that was in 87
88 88
maybe about eight late 88 is [ __ ]
when i left
and then soon after that it rapidly
started to fall apart after i left
even though it had collapsed once
back in the 60s it wasn't as good as it
was in the 60s 50s and 60s was even
better evidently
it was a place of rapid growth
it was the uh
detroit was rivaled
new york easily
easily
it was the industrial center of the
united states they made all the cars
they made a lot of money
even tucker was around for a while
but it was mostly ford chevrolet dodge
they just made them all
they had a lot of [ __ ] money
tyler the guy says being in crime sounds
like hell constantly worrying about who
wants you dead yeah we brought that up
earlier we were talking about cocaine
cowboys and also this situation uh the
money is probably this nice but
you know you're always worried
somebody's gonna like [ __ ] shoot you
in the back of the head which doesn't
sound like a lot of fun
granters hammer says detroit is a
hellscape but the suburbs are classic
americana
says detroit just needs a little
gentrification we'll be back the burbs
are still booming yeah i've heard that
too like a lot of people actually uh
live outside and grantham said i now
live an hour west of detroit woods and
lakes and wildlife god's country super
beautiful and pastoral yeah that's
another thing i forgot michigan has
fantastic woods and and and a natural
beauty
especially up towards the great lakes
area where
there is not a big difference between
detroit
and canada and canada is kind of like a
[ __ ] one huge
[ __ ] national forest i mean it's
pretty up there but it's cold
it's the american siberia it's one of
the coldest places in america
you also said what i'm exactly what was
this last second comment i want everyone
to know that tom is exactly the same as
when we were in high school just more
worldwide but same exact humor and
insight yeah yeah yeah yeah you haven't
changed much no
you pretty much you think your character
is pretty much set by the time you're
[ __ ] 16 17. you stay about the same
it just adds it's adds on to it and then
you die you just get crankier yeah i'm
not cranky anymore though
i started bumping that test i feel
[ __ ] good
you're still kind of cranky
i was the cranky before though i mean
i've i've been cranky my whole entire
life so you know what i mean since i hit
teenage years anyway so i've been
cracking my whole life but uh no i i
mean um
my friend steve still lives up there
also i could live in in in michigan
it's just uh
it's not
it's cold
a lot of the years
and it's
it's not really the center of [ __ ]
attention like the way florida is
florida is kind of like the new version
of california i lived in california too
it's kind of like kellogg but like i
said the way things are nowadays your
location is not as important as it was
but
so yeah which in a way kind of like
opens [ __ ] up because it's like hey man
if i'm gonna like live
out in kind of like the middle of
nowhere but you can still as long as you
still have wi-fi well sophie
sophie came to visit us
sophie's kind of typical for for
michigan that's the way that people are
um they're good people
i don't know i don't know grampus if you
know soph but so
sophie is actually friends with jason's
little sister
and i met sophie through the show and
[ __ ] we didn't realize that this is
how small the world is we didn't realize
that we basically are [ __ ] cousins
if you know if i know you through jason
and [ __ ] steve [ __ ] trenton then
you're like a cousin so sophie's kind of
like a cousin
but uh remember jason's little sister
again that was that was uh sophie was
friends with her
baby she didn't go to trent high though
david june says i'm disappointed there's
been no wigs tonight
[ __ ] man these [ __ ] you forgot
all about your wigs
oh my god going straight into the future
with this [ __ ] then
going straight into the future who's at
this talk about this david jean said all
right david here you go
all right do the wig i'm going to the
back going
[Laughter]
going straight coming in i'm gonna get
my [ __ ]
go ahead
no no i'm gonna go ahead and now where's
the brush
where's the brush no i gotta brush this
[ __ ] by the on-air side it's not by the
on-air side oh i see it yeah
let's buy the illustrious on-air sign
yeah detroit was a trip i got to take
jenny down to detroit
maybe uh
take her to a city club take a city club
in the shelter
i haven't been there forever although i
have
run into some people over at uh
[ __ ] barbarella's downtown orlando
had a couple of girls that were from
michigan that was going still going to
city club pretty regularly and they they
said it was still pretty good
this is a weird place but yeah grapplers
mentioned it he said outside detroit the
suburbs out there like pure americana
yeah they they are
midwest americana i'd say
um kind of a scandinavian background
most of them scandinavian and check and
check
uh you have a lot of eastern european
people a lot of skis kowalski
noewalski
everybody got a name that ends with ski
at the end of it
honkies get up
it's out here
a [ __ ] good friend of mine named mike
kowalski he was ended up owning a damn
remember mike
little skinny ass mike ended up owning a
damn ambulance company
running he was a paramedic for a while
and then
got into the ambulance business because
of course you know detroit needs lots of
ambulances and uh he owns an ambulance
business
go ahead
gee thanks good you stole my brush i got
the brush right here it doesn't matter
he's like [ __ ]
your wig's like all low and you feel
that you're all like [ __ ]
i mean i was almost like to the end so
what i was gonna say was that
even though
uh so this
uh mercury marquee that apparently jimmy
hoffa got picked up in which like i said
a lot of uh witnesses did say they saw
him get into this car with like two or
three other dudes they did actually find
that car later
and they did find a single hair in there
that belonged to jimmy hoffa that
doesn't necessarily mean that he got
killed in that car though
that just means that he was in there at
some point although i think they did
like put um you know kind of cadaver
sniffing dogs on the car
and uh they
smelled jimmy hoffa on the back seat and
in the trunk
so
not sure like some
some sources said that he never left
that particular car they just left him
in that car but like i said that car i
don't think was crushed because they
investigated it later and they found
like why would you crush your car
well i don't know if that was anyone's
car i think that was a rented car
okay to be honest but still you wouldn't
crush that too because then that would
[ __ ] cause that would cost you well
yeah they'd be like hey where'd that car
go
that we run into you you're gonna crush
an old junk car that no one will
question why you're crushing that so
that's not the original car that they
killed him and put him in they probably
they might have put him in and put him
in one card they might have like knocked
him out yeah and then put him in another
one i kind of feel like that's probably
the most likely scenario probably
knowing the mob the way they would do it
is somebody slipped up behind him while
he was
the dude hoff is talking to his buddy
and they're [ __ ] you're planning
something in the future he's not seeing
it but somebody else is coming up behind
him maybe he's in the seat behind him
pops into the back of the head with
something real small like a 22 or a 32.
nothing big nothing that makes a bunch
of noise and then that kills him and
then they put him in the trunk of that
car and then they go okay and they got a
little [ __ ] all pre-planned then they
drive that car to the [ __ ] car they're
gonna crush and put him in that car
and then they put somebody else to drive
that car and then that person drives
that car to the scrap yard and he's
probably a lower echelon guy but they
got a big dude with him watching him
maybe they'll follow him in the car you
know and make sure that he crushes it
this could be something like that
beowulf says what year is this happening
1975 75 19 17. that was the year you
could get away with all kinds of [ __ ]
back in those days i mean that does
sound kind of likely um and it also
sounds likely like i said i don't
believe the thing that frank sheeran was
the one that killed him i think it was
um
uh whatever that dude like uh bregulio
or there was another dude named and what
was the name andretti or andrea or
something like that um he was one of the
ones in the car but
the fact that they had sharon in there
who's a friend of his
was probably like to put him at ease
because like i said i'm sure he was
probably like on guard he probably knew
like people were out to get him and [ __ ]
right yeah um although i will say that
uh i saw an interview
with a dude that was jimmy hoffa's
driver
and he said you know i had coffee with
jimmy hoffa like the day before he
disappeared
and
this dude uh
he even he knew that like some bad [ __ ]
was gonna happen he's like man you you
really need to be careful because people
are gunning for you
and he said allegedly that jimmy hoffa
told him my people won't harm me yeah
those are the ones that killed him
[Laughter]
well and i mean the fact that they had
like one of his friends along
to
and like i said maybe that dude didn't
even know that they were like gonna bump
him off they just said hey we're gonna
like do this thing and we're gonna have
a meeting and why don't you come with us
so i don't know i don't i don't know who
know about it i don't know who's in that
car
but
i mean it's pretty obvious that he got
in that car in the parking lot because a
lot of people saw that
but that was the last time that he was
seen it's kind of funny how mafiosi
[ __ ] don't
don't follow their own rules
because it was well known even in in in
in his time in office time that usually
the ones that get you are your best
friends
but i guess you're kind of in denial
you don't think your best friends are
actually going to be the ones to pull
the trigger on well the thing about it
too you don't want to think that is that
sometimes higher ups might say to your
best friend hey i'm going to whack you
if you don't help us whack him
yeah well
they're doing this for mutual survival
they're all afraid
of going to jail yeah he's a security
risk he's got to go
well
if he starts talking to the cops
who are the first ones that are going to
go to prison
his friends yeah because he's got
information on all his friends you know
he's going to implicate all his friends
so those are the ones that are going to
get him
and they don't have anything against him
they're just seeing him as kind of like
stupid [ __ ] who's going to talk
to the cops
you know
and you know he's just doing what he's
trying to do because he's being squeezed
he's just trying to stay alive but we
can't let this happen
okay
come on jimmy let's go get something to
drink you know i mean it's not it's that
kind of stuff you know what i mean
kind of like
a good analogy would be like in the
walking dead when your friend's been bit
okay yeah it's not his fault that he's
been bit you don't hold it against him
but you got you got to kill him he's
going to turn into a zombie it's that's
the mentality you're talking about this
is business
yeah yeah he's gonna turn
because he's being squeezed
and tyler the guy makes a very good
point friends in the mafia aren't
friends not really yeah yeah well and
like i said that's another aspect of
this whole and this is what we're
talking about when we're talking about
cooking cowboys it's you can't in that
business you can't trust anyone even
people go to jail yeah well even people
that are supposedly your friends and you
can't you really can't and that really
sucks that would be like a shitty way to
live yeah because you can't what if you
got drunk it like said something
incriminating and it's like now that
person that you thought was your friend
is gonna use that against you
um you know you can't relax around
anybody because you never know um if
that person's really your friend if
they're just getting close to you to get
information or
if they're just like trying to step on
you to get to a greater position or
whatever it is you can't ever like
trust anybody
and i kind of feel like that was the
situation here
and
maybe i don't think jimmy hoffa was
naive
but
um
because he knew the game he knew the
[ __ ] that was going on but it seems like
they still [ __ ] got to him anyway
yeah because i think he was naive enough
to think that maybe there was a couple
people that could still be trusted and
apparently there was not he was grasping
for straws
he was thinking that he's he was
different that's what it was no well
everybody thinks that everybody thinks
that everybody thinks that he got always
get you into he was getting squeezed he
got bit he was a security risk he had to
go he didn't think his friends would do
it but there are all his friends they
were they were his friends though they
liked him it's just that his friends are
all start
their their own survival is paramount
everybody has to [ __ ] survive well
and like i said you're not gonna go to
jail the thing about it too yeah not
only are they afraid to go to jail but
if higher ups are
squeezing them to like get rid of this
dude there's basically like look we're
gonna bump you off are you gonna [ __ ] up
your family we're gonna kill your family
if you don't like get in on this there's
no choice it's almost kind of yeah it's
they don't really have it's like a
military operation yeah basically
so they just wait he got to go
he's going to lead to us
we got to it's all about foiling
investigations
well and that's essentially what they
were doing because jimmy hoffa i mean
like i said
credit to him for at least being ballsy
enough to like stick to his principles
but the fact that he stuck to his
principles and he basically came out and
said hey i'm gonna like tell everybody
about your mob ties yeah
maybe maybe not such a smart thing to do
when like you also have mob ties yeah
i'm just saying uh because they're gonna
like come get you and be like oh well i
guess we need to shut you up then
permanently so i kind of feel like
that's what happened um you know so i
don't think anyone's disputing i know
there are a couple like fringe theories
out there that
uh that he actually
uh was a lot well he wouldn't be alive
now because he'd be like 100 something
years old but um that he was alive for a
long time like in mafia custody or that
he was in the witness protection program
i did not buy that at all i think 99.99
of people are pretty sure that he got
bumped off they just don't know who
exactly who was the trigger man and
where exactly the body ended up yeah
that's really the only mystery sandra if
you want to see another couple cool
detroit movies all right i know you like
these movies you're trying to put
america into the into perspective
see beverly hills cop one and two with
eddie murphy
he starts off as a detroit cop who has
to go to beverly hills all right and you
see the difference between detroit and
beverly hills one and two is great three
nah
but one and two i don't even remember
three what happened in that one three
was poorly written
but here's the good thing on the back of
coming to america two which is a good
movie yeah i liked it it was all right
it's not as good as one but it was good
really [ __ ]
that other movie that he came out with
was [ __ ] bad ass i like that one
about [ __ ] um
it's about randy raymore yeah rudy ray
moore what was it called
is my name god that movie is so good
great movie
masterpiece that would be so good
there's supposedly going to be a new
beverly hills cop coming out
i had heard that also i would love to
see that
[ __ ] i love the axle foley character
[ __ ] for me [ __ ]
eddie murphy was axel foley that's like
it was a good character detroit [ __ ]
cop who you who was kind of crooked but
he was a good guy he's a good guy
but see berber hills cop one and two
very good
fun movie fun movie good 80s soundtrack
um got some you know
yeah it's got some funny humor in it and
[ __ ] some action happens and some
americanisms happen america 80s
americanisms happen through that through
both of those whole [ __ ] movies right
there they're a good movie
i mean you have to say though that in
the 80s like a lot of those movies were
idealized to a certain extent yeah
but they captured the spirit they did
they captured the they were to a large
extent id line they were mostly idolized
but they there's something about the
soundtrack and the way things happened
they captured the spirit of the place
and time they were very good at that can
i say at least the least of that movie
was that's why it's remembered yeah um
you know they didn't always but a lot of
them did
one thing that kind of made me laugh
about a lot of
particularly john hughes movies in the
1980s which i love i'm not saying that
but i'm i'm thinking about like pretty
in pink
pretty like molly ringwald's character
she said she watched them back in the
days she didn't remember or anything
yeah i don't know i remember the first
one but i don't remember the second of
the second one was kind of like the
first one but better it had a bigger
budget
yeah it was good but one thing that i
thought of
was that
particularly pretty in pink yeah um
molly ringwald's character was supposed
to be i mean she had a single parent who
was a dad who was unemployed so they
were supposed to be like lower middle
class
and one thing that always struck me when
i watched that movie in the 1980s i'm
like they have a nicer house than i have
yeah she has a phone in her room i don't
have that
it's like what the [ __ ] what are you
bitching about
um because we had a shared line so i did
have but um when i first saw that movie
and like whenever it came out in 85 or
whatever it came out uh i was kind of
like what are you bitching about it's
like that's way nicer than my house you
have a car i don't have a car what the
[ __ ] you know what i mean so it was kind
of like i don't know that was like
really funny to me so things so even
poor people like in those movies back
then like had more [ __ ] than actual poor
people
but i don't know and some of the like
super yuppy characters were i mean i
didn't know some characters like that
but it did seem like it was like
exaggerated crap just comes out because
some people talk about detroit movies
granted says be mile for robocop eight
mile eight by eight mile yeah i got my i
got my [ __ ]
glasses on eight mile robocop gran
torino and gross point blank yeah i
remember those oh my god gross point
blank was so good yeah i saw that in the
theater too i haven't seen that a long
time that was john cusack i have a very
[ __ ] soft heart for [ __ ] beverly
hills cop one and two though they just
me and mike used to watch those things
me and mike kowalski used to watch those
things we just [ __ ] loved axel foley
without [ __ ] eddie murphy was funny
as [ __ ] and that
and the the the humor does kind of
translate over time humor tends to get
stale as it ages yeah we were talking
about that yeah we talked about that
earlier it's still pretty good it's a
good character
another one there's a couple other
movies i really liked [ __ ] uh golden
child
aged pretty well it was fun movie to see
again although i will say i did i loved
that movie like when it was first out in
the 80s i didn't like it as much
watching it now but i still liked it i
didn't like it as much as i did back
then and then uh
i needed to re-watch vampire in brooklyn
really good at age yeah i liked that as
well you know another one that i watched
a lot like back in the 80s that i need
to re-watch is romancing the stone yeah
we want to see that one again um i think
it's on hulu or something like that
because i saw it when i was scrolling
through i was like oh man i need to like
[ __ ] watch that again because i saw
that a million times in that yeah i
liked it it was the budget version of
raiders of the lost ark that's how i
remembered it it i felt it felt like
raiders are lost yeah it was like an
adventure romance yeah like a romance
version of raiders and lost art yeah i
thought it was good though i liked the
chemistry between michael douglas and uh
kathleen around the time that came out
though [ __ ] commando one came out and
that [ __ ] was commando and that [ __ ]
was kind of like a
like a video game on screen
i still like that movie as cheesy as
that [ __ ] is being so
so over the top over the [ __ ] top
that is [ __ ] broke that broke off
and and
there was another movie
that had dolph longren
that i associate
with [ __ ]
with [ __ ] commander called red
scorpion remember that yeah i remember
that i haven't seen it since i was a kid
i mean yeah i don't remember if it's any
good or not i remember liking it it was
dolph lundgren being kind of like
an action hero
red scorpion he was a russian he was a
russian version of [ __ ] arnold of
course he was because of course yeah you
had to see it you know i want to see
that one again tyler the guy says stir
of echoes is the only movie i've ever
seen that had an actually realistic
looking middle to lower middle class
household in it that was one of the
things and i love that movie honestly
anybody that likes
ghost story type [ __ ]
that is a really underrated movie um
everybody forgot about it because it
came out almost exactly the same time as
that [ __ ] m night uh
shyamalan movie uh what the [ __ ] is it
called the one with the i see dead
people oh yeah [ __ ] six cents six
cents here so it came out like pretty
much the same week or two weeks later or
something like that so it kind of get
overshadowed but stir of echoes it's
based on richard matheson novel um and
it's really really good kevin bacon is
in it but yeah they actually do show an
actual working class
family
in an actual working class house and a
working-class neighborhood and it's like
it's seeing that movie you like you see
how unusual that is to like see that in
a hollywood movie because i kind of feel
like one thing it's maybe not so much
nowadays but i kind of feel like
something that i saw a lot in the 80s
was that
um they'd put these characters in movies
that were living in
uh situations that i was like okay
you're a teacher or you're this or that
or a cop or something like that and
you're living in this nice houses like
that would not happen in real life
uh everyone was living in like way
better conditions than they would
actually be able to afford yeah um which
was something that i noticed like i said
and it was something i noticed a lot in
john hughes movies because
you know even the working-class people
and they're like lived in nicer
conditions than i did
so and they were supposedly like didn't
have jobs and [ __ ] and it was just kind
of like i don't know it was just like
funny to me that everything was like
that exaggerated
getting back to the [ __ ] weird
detroit [ __ ] if you guys want to see
something go on youtube and you can look
at like detroit's
detroit urban exploration videos
and one of the most interesting ones is
mike tyson's abandoned mansion
there are people that are going in there
and making videos of it that was the
mansion that mike tyson used to own
when he was a champion
in his teens married to robin givens
and they'll take you inside of his
[ __ ] house in downtown detroit not in
downtown but right outside detroit
it's been abandoned for over 30 years
and it's a trip because you know he was
[ __ ] robin gibbons up in that place
it's got lofts and indoor [ __ ]
swimming pools
and and it's got all kinds it's got a
big old [ __ ] gate
and the the
the lawn is all overgrown it's it's down
the end of a private road
nobody's been in there for a long time
go go go look on youtube with [ __ ]
mike tyson's abandoned mansion it's
spooky in a way
but it's just weird grafters is in there
he'll tell you
it was weird that there was such a big
thriving city there that slowly just
[ __ ] vanished in an apocalyptic wave
of exodus
of people and money leaving
he says the the the suburbs around it
are doing well
my buddy steve is still doing well there
it's just it's weird how there was a
city that once rivaled new york that is
now like a fraction of what it used to
be
there's kind of they've torn a lot of
the neighborhoods down now
they've been returned to the wilderness
it's just grass trees and [ __ ] empty
fields
they tore [ __ ] big old [ __ ] brick
whole blocks whole sectors of [ __ ]
neighborhoods were torn down and they
were brick from the 1800s late 1800s
early 1900s gone return to nature
it's like a like an apocalypse
it's [ __ ] weird
there is a downtown area it looks decent
but it's just office buildings you know
there's still a few million people there
but
they don't have to be there they're just
living in little apartments and stuff
there's not much of an economy down
there it's all in the suburbs now
it's just weird weird go check out mike
tyson's [ __ ] abandoned mansion it's a
trip
it's tacky too
tacky of course it is big old open
spaces with a [ __ ]
he's got he had one place there's a big
old open
space with a swimming pool in it and
then a loft
where you could sleep and look over over
watch the swimming pool
and there was a bunch of other stuff in
there it was very kind of
kind of 80s looking
you know
yeah and it was just like damn him and
robin gibbons were living up in that
[ __ ]
back in the day
robin gibbons remember her mm-hmm yeah
yeah i remember
yeah before they got yeah before that
[ __ ] wouldn't happen before he started
punching the [ __ ] out of her i don't
know if that actually happened uh i
imagine it probably did
[Laughter]
there's no telling i'm not sure that
actually happened he's a nice guy he's
got issues uh but um
i think it was more like that was kind
of an arranged marriage and money had a
lot to do with it her her mom was
involved in a lot of that
and
he was a young dude you know i mean i
think he had egger issues you know
it's hard to give a dude that comes from
nothing and just give him a millions of
dollars
you know
robin came from money she had money for
before she met him
basically compared to him at least
but
she was looking for money there's no
there's no talent
yeah there's not i wasn't there i'm just
saying
yeah
yeah karen roberts pointed out yeah i'm
like how can they afford to live in that
home i kind of feel like that with most
movies and tv shows that i watch
um
people that have certain jobs
in certain cities like especially if
they live in like a big city like new
york city or san francisco or somewhere
like that and it's like oh i'm like a
teacher and i live in this like this
really nice apartment i'm like yeah in
real life unless you inherited a [ __ ]
ton of money from your family that is
not the type of place you would live in
there goes tom detroit's right there i
can see it dude go look at mike tyson's
[ __ ] abandoned mansion [ __ ]
saunders i just looked at what she said
mike tyson's house has been empty since
1999 why does nobody move there it's
such a big thing
um yes then america is large somebody
should like move in and like squat in it
and actually i might go that's why
i think people don't realize how big the
united states is there are there are
areas of it that are abandoned there are
there are towns that are abandoned
that everyone kind of forgot he just
left yeah
and um
nobody lives in mike tyson's house
because that's not worth anything and
it's on worthless land
uh that's all gone there's no economy to
support that
it's gone
but go look at mike tyson's [ __ ]
abandoned mansion it's there
and there's lots of that
lots and lots well people like a long
time ago would build a mansion in a
place that and sometimes it was a little
bit isolated but sometimes it was in a
place where there was a town not that
far away and then if the town kind of
like economically went you know declined
or whatever and then or that family's
you know economy declined uh and then
they just left it there
essentially like the forest just
reclaims it yeah uh and then some
urban explorer comes across it one day
like hey look at this like mansion
sitting here and all their [ __ ] still in
it and there's a lot of super weird and
lots of it i encourage you to look at
urban exploration videos
there are
whole vacation result resorts that were
built in the 60s and the 70s
sitting out in the middle of the woods
well some of my favorite dan bell videos
are ones that i think they're like up in
the poconos and stuff like that um where
you know back in the 60s and 70s that
was a bit like a really hot like
vacation
destination um which people still go
there nowadays but not to that part of
it so they built like these like these
fabulous like hotels with nightclubs and
restaurants and stuff in there and it's
like then they got abandoned like in the
90s usually they got abandoned
yeah there's this concept that
everything's crowded
it's not crowded
if you live in a downtown area in an
american city you might perceive the
world as being crowded
there are people that live in these
cities whose feet have never been off of
pavement or concrete their feet has
never touched soil
and so in their mind they're going to
tell you that it's overpopulated and
crowded
there are
whole towns
that have been forgotten in america that
people haven't been to in forever
look at express
look at urban exploration videos you'll
see
there they will go into houses where the
owners died in the 80s
and the owner had no
relatives
and the house has been sitting there
untouched since 1988 and everything
still works and the power is still on
because everyone just forgot about it
everyone just forgot about it you go in
there and the damn refrigerator and the
freezer still work well there was that
one video that you showed me the other
day where like they they actually went
in this house which had been abandoned
all the furniture was still there and
they were actually still videotapes and
they could put them in the vcr and like
watch him and watch him watch dude's
video because the power was still on
that was that clock maker yeah it was
super creepy and his car was in the damn
driveway looked like he could drive it
it was all the air was gone out of the
tires probably all the gasoline
evaporated
but it looked clean it looked like you
could and the car looked brand new but
it was [ __ ] decades old sitting right
there it hasn't been driven forever and
you could live in that house nobody's
been in there since the late 80s
yeah everything's like the power is
still on everything worked you could
flush the toilet it had water had power
everything and it looked like the dude
just got up and left
another dude died a long time ago and
none of his relatives ever claimed it
nobody owns that house
maybe the state but the state forgets
about things they don't care
so you could go right into the house and
live in it it's not in the little
country
but there's a lot of that
well i mean like i said when the few
times we've driven out to my mom's house
because my mom lives out in ocala
national forest
um you know just 10 15 minutes from here
is
miles and miles and miles of nothing
nothing in forest nothing yeah it's just
the united states is not crowded
there might be houses out there for all
we know i'm sure there probably are well
i told jenny i was in being mississippi
and i found a [ __ ] thicket of [ __ ]
woods and [ __ ] started pulling
through it and saw a victorian house in
there it was totally overgrown there was
nothing in it [ __ ] floors had
collapsed the windows had all been
broken out it was scary it was like a
[ __ ] cave
but that house was from the 1800s late
1800s well like i said why do you think
people are so fascinated by those urban
exploration videos because
you know there's still vast swathes of
the united states that used to be like
back in the old days
you know in the railroad days or
whatever like there was towns there and
[ __ ] like that but over time they just
got forgotten about so there's all these
houses that just went back to nature and
everybody just forgot they were there
because everybody that would know about
the people that lived there are dead now
so nobody really owns it it's just kind
of out in the woods the entire town of
centralia
is just sitting there abandoned
look up centralia
yeah because that underground they had
an underground coal it's pretty that's
pretty famous yeah it's still burning
yeah still burning underneath the ground
in a coal mine fire and the gases that
made it dangerous to live there so they
just evacuated so there's still a town
but all the houses are abandoned
abandoned sitting there forever and it's
got videotapes in some of the houses
they've gone in there everybody just
left yeah i just left and it kind of
like chernobyl it's creepy yeah it's
creepy yeah i think uh
dan bell did a video there well a lot of
urban exploration channels have done
like videos there because it's kind of
famous like in the us that town uh
because
yeah it's like it's not a massive town
or anything it's just like a little town
but all the houses are abandoned sandra
just says creepy we don't know what
you're talking about sandra no she said
crazy crazy i think it's a creepy yeah
about all the urban exploit like that
everything just like being abandoned
yeah yeah there's lots of it
they have a dude that did did a little
video he bought a mining town
i can't remember where that was new
mexico
and he
there's a lot of silver mines though
yeah he bought a mining town it already
had buildings in it and everything in a
mine had been abandoned for a long time
30s or 40s
and he's revived it so he lives in this
abandoned mining town out in the middle
of desert he's pumping his own water
rebuilding it people are coming to visit
him he's got a [ __ ]
patreon page and making videos of what
he's doing in the town and the [ __ ]
it used to have like
a couple hundred people living and it's
just him now
living in this town making videos i like
that idea yeah maybe i could find it
owns a whole town
in the middle of the desert
well every time we see like an urban
exploration video where like there's
just some mansion in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere yeah and it looks like
it's in okay shape yeah i'm just kind of
like what if i could just go move into
that yeah
i would imagine that looks pretty nice
sandra i would imagine you as a german
would freak the [ __ ] out because i know
you guys are like all authoritarian and
always worried about who owns what and
where everything is
you can find urban exploration videos of
them where they will find a [ __ ]
mansion
here in the united states
built in the 90s of the 2000 that looks
[ __ ] perfect i'm talking about a mega
mansion with basketball courts and
[ __ ] jacuzzis and bowling lanes and
everything nobody's been in there for
20 or 30 years and you can go in there
and it's just pristine and it's out in
the middle of nowhere
you could and they know who owned it and
why they sold it but they're not worth
anything
it's not like people think if you build
a mansion and all of a sudden you ha
it's worth something and you can sell it
no well it depends on where it's at no
i mean if nobody wants to live there
then the [ __ ] is useless mansions are a
great way to throw away money in the
united states you'll make more money on
a little house like this okay which is a
little house compared to a mansion
people that can afford mansions can
afford to build a mansion and they want
a brand new mansion made made to theirs
because why wouldn't you why the [ __ ]
would you want to build
buy
a used mansion to someone else's
specifications
so these guys will [ __ ] build a four
or five million dollar mansion two
million dollar mansion in a location and
then they die
or they lose their money or they never
go to it so they sell it or just kind of
abandon it because they got other
mansions and the [ __ ] just sits there
nobody will ever buy it
it'll just fall it's not worth anything
it's not worth anything to a rich person
because like you said they have enough
money to build their own [ __ ] because
like i said if you have millions of
dollars
if i had millions of dollars i'd be like
yeah i want to build a house to my
specifications i don't want somebody
else's crap yep and i guess a bank owns
it
i guess is what it ends up happening to
it but the bank doesn't really give a
[ __ ]
you could probably move into something
like that if you were taking care of it
if if anyone ever came by to ask any
questions that might be a couple years
which probably they wouldn't probably
never but somebody might come in what
are you doing i'm the teacher i'm the
caretaker you're the caretaker yeah the
bank sent me here to take care of it all
right fair enough and if they believe
that they just let you go
no okay
you'd be squatting in it i mean as long
as it was kind of out in the middle of
nowhere and you weren't bothering me
yeah i don't think they'd really give a
crap
yeah as long as you're taking care of
things you weren't damaging things and
what's funny is that those mansions
always have the power on
maybe it will be like rich people don't
pay for power it doesn't matter
either that or it's like not enough for
anybody to notice they don't notice it
if you were in there [ __ ] running
them lights i imagine they'd eventually
notice it why are you draining all this
power yeah somebody would like it would
red flag to somebody but i kind of feel
like most people are working the power
can be just like regular work and joe's
and they're just kind of like whatever i
don't give a crap
so as long as it's not like
raising any red flags probably nobody
cares i would think yeah
tammy says uh on the next dan bell i
found hoffa
wouldn't that be funny if he was just
like exploring like damn damn abandoned
house and like [ __ ] fountains dan
just released a video either today or
yesterday explaining where he's been and
he's been having mental problems oh he
has a new one out yeah okay i'm gonna
have some kind of mental problems so
he's not he hasn't been posting videos
he's got [ __ ] uh
poor dan yeah i love dan yeah he's got
good [ __ ] he's he's a good he's a good
dude like i said i need to go on his
patreon because he's got like a bunch of
extra content on there
and i have to like check that out
got to the end of the jimmy hoffa stuff
yeah we did
i mean you know nobody knows what
happened but i mean everybody knows what
happened to him but nobody knows exactly
what happened you know what i mean it's
still a mystery i don't think they're
ever going to solve that because like i
said i don't think his body even exists
his body doesn't exist it was destroyed
yeah they whether they i don't think
they fed it to the ship we fed it to
sharks or pigs or put it in a
you know car compactor or whatever but
it's like they they got rid they didn't
just bury it somewhere they got rid of
that [ __ ] they compacted that [ __ ] and
they put him in a trunk and [ __ ]
crushed the car and melted it
yeah no need for me too says they just
leave it connected to the grid because
they forget to unhook it all that's kind
of what i think happens
and it's not like drawing enough power
to like have anybody's attention like
nobody notices that no one's paying for
it right um you know if it doesn't raise
any red flags like i said no one's going
to really notice you could literally go
into that mansion and live in there and
nobody would notice you the problem is
that those matches are [ __ ] huge if
you see the mansions we're talking about
a lot of empty spaces
in florida something like that would
cost thousands and thousands probably
two thousand three thousand dollars a
month to air condition
and you need to air condition it because
otherwise it will just it'll mold
they'll just be molded a lot of the ones
that they show aren't here in florida we
do have huge [ __ ] mansions here in
florida but they got to be running air
conditioning [ __ ] during the summer
um because [ __ ] man we couldn't live in
there we just had the power off a few
days because of a hurricane and
already molds well [ __ ] a little bit i i
have to keep spraying bleach in the
shower because i'm old and we have air
conditioning yeah which is drying the
[ __ ] out so even if you have air
conditioning you still have like it's a
constant battle against [ __ ] mold
because of the humidity you know what i
mean yeah all right so we're so we're
done with this story we pretty much yeah
i'm starving yeah we're i got food you
got like more well eat that chicken yeah
yeah chicken and veggies he grilled some
more chicken today but he put curry yeah
grilled chicken curry and grilled
vegetables and grilled vegetables it was
really oh we're so healthy
other than all the booze i've lost a lot
of fat
other than all the booze we're like
super healthy i've lost several pounds
of fat in the past couple of couple uh
days i think a couple weeks probably
victor says no don't leave me yeah
we've been going almost four hours
though yeah it's a long show i mean you
know we covered most of the [ __ ] right i
think it turned out okay some of this
looks like you're getting running or are
you done drinking wait is this the apple
yeah it's apple okay because we're out
of the uh
coconut right here [ __ ] right
yeah and i can't drink all that anyway
oh okay well i'll help you out
so yeah so uh tomorrow's saturday so
we're to take a break tomorrow like i
said gotta meet with the landlords
find out what that situation is going to
be do you want to buy this house
we'll see how that goes okay i don't
know how it's going to go like i said we
might have to buy this house or we might
have to move i'm not really entirely
sure what's going to happen um but
sunday
well okay so yesterday we went to the
movie theater
and saw that marvel movie yeah
uh what is it called charlotte
yeah it was pretty which is actually
pretty decent yeah i actually quite
enjoyed it um so we'll probably talk
about that sunday tomorrow we're
probably going to go see malignant the
james juan movie if we have time uh so
then maybe we can talk about that on
monday because that looks pretty good
i'm not a massive like i liked the
conjuring i like james wan's movies
they're fine
um
so this one looked like it was going to
be fine like entertaining
so
we'll probably go see that tomorrow if
we have time and then we'll talk about
it now we have to move it won't be far
no we're not going anywhere like
it would just be around here like 10 15
miles away at the most yeah because i
don't want to like move any farther we
got too many friends around here away
yeah we have like a massive
uh there's a lot of good houses 15 miles
out and a 15 mile radius from here is a
lot of good houses
i'm not worried about it
got the houses we got the money we got
[ __ ]
financial [ __ ] sport
loans and [ __ ] it's just the time and
the [ __ ] the hassle that's that's
that's all yeah because we weren't
really expecting it yeah just like we
just kind of out of the blue well we
don't know what they want yeah i know
what they were kind of like hey can we
come over to the house tomorrow we got
something to tell you in person and i
was just like uh she didn't want us to
[ __ ] buy the house
well because they have they
asked us about it before they asked
about it before and it's been we've been
here for 10 years they're like let's go
ahead and say but the price wasn't right
and they're asking too much for it
but we'll see we'll see we'll see what's
going on we'll see yeah but we got to
meet with them tomorrow morning so we'll
see yeah we'll tell you guys what
happened on sunday
but like i said we don't know we're
going to decide to do we just have to
like see we'll have time to figure [ __ ]
out i hope so i'm not gonna well i'm
gonna give them an answer
okay i don't think no what's the average
home price in florida says louis it
depends on what kind of house you're
talking about um in this area i kind of
feel like the houses are around around
here around 400 000. they're nice though
in this area um for nice like this i'm
talking like a large like two thousand
twenty five hundred square foot four
bedroom four bedroom three bath yeah two
living rooms a [ __ ] dan yeah
victor says move to texas
thank you victor now i fly take florida
over texas i like texas texas is good
but i'd rather have floyd i've never
been in texas i've been in new mexico
i've been to colorado i like those but
i've never been in texas i don't think
florida's wilder and texas is wild too
though they're both wild tammy says go
squat in the haunted mansion at disney
yeah
i honestly if i could if i could afford
to decorate a house like the haunted
mansion assistant i would totally do
that
no shame victor sent us five dollars to
move to texas yeah i know i just said
that florida and texas are similar
they're they're already similar
yeah i think i'd rather take tax florida
though
victor says texas is booming and our
buildings don't collapse
[Laughter]
it's the same thing with [ __ ] florida
though florida's booming also
the building's class but that's south
florida that's way down and that was
that that building [ __ ] man i don't need
the [ __ ] hands although i'm still
worried about this i still worry about
um sinkholes yeah because you never
honestly you never know when that's
gonna happen because days and [ __ ]
yeah just you're just going about your
average life and then all of a sudden
chew the [ __ ] ground like gives out
underneath you and like sucks down five
or six houses that particular building
itself that particular building in miami
though that was a [ __ ] drug building
that was from the [ __ ] that was a
drug money building that's why that [ __ ]
fell it's like they built that [ __ ] at a
paper mache and [ __ ] they knew they knew
that [ __ ] was falling [ __ ] out of god
and moved the [ __ ] out of there
yeah but i kind of feel like a house
like this in this area is around 400
000.
um there are some newer ones that
they're building
in this area that are
around that four hundred thousand to
five hundred thousand but like i said
they're big nice houses
like you know twenty five hundred square
feet four yeah you get the boot
we're not going to get the boot man
[ __ ]
we better not after yeah
no we're going to get the boot [ __ ]
uh we we either have to buy this one or
we have to [ __ ] buy another one
that's all it is
we're going to see we just haven't
decided what we want to do yet do we
want to buy this house or do we want to
like look for another place and really
the best thing going for this house is
two things our stuff is already in it
yeah we don't have to move that's that's
good two the location is really good
i do like this location yeah other than
that it's not that special for this area
yeah well yeah there's a lot of houses
there's a lot of houses like this and
you go 10 miles the other way for the
same price you can get almost twice the
house like i said i do like that this is
right by
the trail
and i do like that it's right by the
highway yeah like i-4 is literally like
a mile or a mile and a half that's what
makes this house worth what it is and
downtown sanford is like but we don't
commute so five or ten minutes we don't
compete it's not as big a deal as it
used to be i mean it used to be a bigger
deal when i had to like drive to work
right but i don't have to do that
anymore
so it's not as big a deal so i'd be more
willing to move out but i still don't
want to like live out in the middle of
nowhere 425 we can go 10 miles out that
way and get a [ __ ] palace
we could get this house for probably
[ __ ] 275 300.
but like i said if we could find
something like that yeah
um and like i said one thing that i
would like that this house does not have
i would like to have like a big screen
porch area so i can build a catio yeah
for the kitties yeah so they can so they
don't have to go outside outside but
they can still be pretend outside
without having to worry about them
getting like hurt or eaten by animals
because that's something that i kind of
worry about around here all right let's
shut it down i'm gonna go get some meat
yeah i'm starving all right so uh we'll
be back have a good
weekend we'll back on sunday like i said
talking about the new marvel movie
because we saw it yesterday
so thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for all your super chats it's
been super fun hanging out with you guys
on this friday night and we will see you
guys on sunday afternoon have a good
saturday
bye